THE SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
BATES.
BELL [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
BRADFORD.
COPY AT ALL [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
THERE ARE ALSO [inaudible]
GALGIANI.
GLAZER.
GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HILL.
HUESO -- TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
THE REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN -- TO TINO [inaudible]
RUBIO.
SKINNER.
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER.
WHY COUNTY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
BOOK WE WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER
THIS MORNING FIRE CHAPLAIN.
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
BY SENATOR PENN.
LET US REMEMBER.
BUT THE FORCES WITH US.
ABRAHAM JOSHUA HESCHEL SAID.
THE ACT OF BRINGING THE WORLD
INTO EXISTENCE IS A CONTINUOUS
PROCESS.
EVERY INSTANCES AN ACT OF
CREATION.
A MOMENT IS NOT A TERMINAL BUT A
FLASH A SIGN OF BEGINNING.
GRACIOUS AND LOVING GODS.
YOU CONTINUALLY CALL US INTO
BEING AND TO INVITE US TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE ONGOING
EVOLUTION OF OUR WORLD.
GIVE US WISDOM TO BE ATTENTIVE
TO THE IMPLICATIONS OF OUR
ACTIONS AND NON ACTIONS.
GIVE US FOR TO TO TO PERSEVERE
IN THE FACE OF THOSE WHO WOULD
DEVOLVE ALL THAT HAS BEEN
ACHIEVED.
GIVE US ENOUGH LOVE TO CONTINUE
TO BRING TO BIRTH YOUR DREAM FOR
THE UNITY OF ALL HUMANKIND.
WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME AMEN.
OUR NATION'S FLAG I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED [inaudible]
PUBLIC CANCEL.
SAN ANDREAS -- INDIVISIBLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS WE
HAVE A FAIRLY BUSY DAY TODAY SO
WE'RE GOING.
TO MOVE THROUGH THE AGENDA I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS SO WE CAN -- UP.
GO THROUGH THE AGENDA QUICKLY --
THAT I NEXT ITEM ON OUR AGENDA
IS PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
WE'RE GONNA DEFERRED THAT
PARTICULAR.
MATTER FOR A FEW MINUTES.
AND TAKE IT UP LATER SO MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED.
UNDER THE NEXT ITEM IN IS
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR APRIL TWENTY NINTH
THROUGH MAY SECOND. TWENTY
NINETEEN WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
MOVING ON MEMBERS TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
THE FIRST ITEM.
THERE IS THE SECOND.
READING FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH
FIFTEEN SECRETARY MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY SIX
THREE SEVENTY FOUR SEVENTY NINE
SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS THREE NINETY EIGHT
FIVE FORTY FOUR SENATE BILL
FORTY ONE WITH THE MOMENTS ONE
EIGHTY WITH AMENDMENTS THREE
SEVENTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS TO
SECOND READING WILL BE DEEMED
READ.
MOVING ON TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS [inaudible]
SENATOR WILK.
ARE YOU PREPARED ON THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT.
FILE ITEM.
SIXTEEN THANK YOU ARE PRESENT
FILE I'M SIXTEEN IS A
CONFIRMATION OF THOMAS PORTER AS
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION.
MISTER PORTER HAS SERVE CAL FIRE
OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS IN
VARIOUS CAPACITIES INCLUDING
STANCE IS A SOUTHERN REGION
CHIEF.
AND UNIT FIRE CHIEF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY HE'S ALSO REGISTER
PROFESSIONAL FORESTER HE WAS
APPOINTED I MEAN EXCUSE ME WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON APRIL THIRD.
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
SENATOR [inaudible]
JACKSON.
YES THANK YOU UP MAN PRESENT
COLLEGE I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
MR PORTER CHEAP PORTER I HAD THE
HONOR AND PRIVILEGE AND SAD.
MOMENT OF WORKING WITH HIM ON
THE THOMAS FIRE AND ALSO WHEN I
WAS SHARING THE JOINT COMMITTEE
ON EMERGENCY SERVICES HOW HE'S
FEELING SOME PRETTY BIG SHOES.
BUT IF ANYONE CAN DO IT IT'S
MISTER PORTER HE HAS BEEN
OUTSTANDING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL CLEARLY BENEFIT
FROM HIS SERVICES AND I
ENTHUSIASTICALLY ORIGIN AYE VOTE
ON HIS.
APPOINTMENT.
VERY GOOD SENATOR NIELSEN.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN CENTER DIE RISE IN
SUPPORT AS WELL TOM PORTER AS
OUR DIRECTOR OF FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION.
HE'S A LONG TIME.
MEMBER OF THAT FIND ORGANIZATION.
AND HE HAD HAS BEEN THROUGH.
THIS YEAR.
AS HAVE MANY TRULY A TRIAL BY
FIRE.
AND HE HAS PERFORMED
MAGNIFICENTLY AS HAS HIS
ORGANIZATION.
HE INSPIRES THE TRUST AND
CONFIDENCE OF THE PEOPLE THAT HE
WORKS WITH.
HIS FELT THAT TO BE ONE OF THEM.
AND THAT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
REQUIREMENT.
IN THESE TOUGH TIMES FOR
CALIFORNIA.
HE'S BEEN VERY EASY AND
ACCESSIBLE TO WORK WITH WITH ALL
OF THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED THESE FIRE DISASTERS.
HE'S WELL WORTHY OF OUR SUPPORT.
AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE.
THING NINE MISTER SECRETARY THE
ROLE [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BY.
ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CARRIER.
HI HI.
CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DODD [inaudible]
THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER.
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
BY HILL [inaudible]
HI HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
HI JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK I AM A REAL.
BY NIELSEN.
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE BY
ROSS [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE.
BY AMBERG BY WHAT CASKEY.
BY WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI.
MISTER SECRETARY WOULD COULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
BEL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
DODD.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SENATOR WELCOME.
MOVES A CALL.
WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
SEVENTEEN MISTER WELK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS PHYLUM SEVENTEEN IS A
CONFIRMATION A DAVID HOAX FIELD
FOR RE APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
MR HOPE.
HOPE HOPE CHAU EXCUSE ME WAS
FIRST APPOINTED TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN AND GOVERNOR NEWSOME
HAS DESIGNATED HIM TO SERVICE
THE NEW CHAIR.
PARDEE SERVING ON THE COMMISSION
HIS VICE PRESIDENT EXTERNAL
RELATIONS AT SALARIO CORP HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON APRIL TENTH ANY UNANIMOUS
VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION.
DEBATE.
THING -- NINE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
I BILL.
HI PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
BY KELLY AT ALL HI I CHIANG.
BY DODD.
HI THE RUSSELL.
I GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
HI.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY THE TITLE.
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA [inaudible]
I'M ACQUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
HI PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE.
NUMBER.
I WOULD COUNTY.
I WIENER.
HI WILK.
HI. SIX THIRTY MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
WARLOCK [inaudible]
I MORRELL [inaudible]
STONE.
IS THAT -- FIVE SIX VOTES TWO
VOTES NO [inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
IS CONFIRMED.
MEMBERS MOVING BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER.
SIXTEEN WELL THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE'RE GONNA LET THE CALL
[inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
HI -- TITLE BY [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
HI. THIRTY EIGHT EYES NOSE.
ZERO THE APARTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
EIGHTEEN SENATOR WELLS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBERS
EIGHTEEN IS A CONFIRMATION OF
MICHAEL JANAE TO THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION.
MR CHEN AYE IS THE SENIOR
FORESTRY VISOR FOR MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANY AND HUMBLED
REDWOOD COMPANY AND HE'S A
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL FORSTER
IN CALIFORNIA.
HE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON APRIL TENTH AT A
FIVE OH VOTE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
MISTER SECRETARY THE ROLE PLEASE
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES.
I BILL.
BY PORGES.
HI BRADFORD.
AYE CAMBIADO HI I CHIANG.
I DOT.
BY THE RUSSELL.
AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GROWTH.
AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
HI MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK.
BY MERRELL [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
BY PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER.
I STERN AYE STONE.
BY AMBERG.
PILOT CASKEY BY WINNER HI WILK
OUR ZERO FIVE THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN SENATOR WILK THEY CAME
OUT OF PRESIDENT IN MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN IS A
CONFIRMATION OF KATHLEEN ALAVI.
BILL HANNAH HARTWIG AND JANE
MARKS TO THE COMMISSION OF
TEACHER CREDENTIALING.
AND CHRISTINA LARSON TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA ALL
THESE APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL
TENTH ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
THERE -- PLEASE [inaudible]
ALLEN.
BY ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES.
AYE BILL.
I PORGES.
I BRADFORD AYE COMING AT ALL HI
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
HI HUESO. FOR TITLE.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
HI JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA [inaudible]
TIME ACQUIRE.
I BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL.
HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
HI ROSS.
HI RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE.
HI MY COUNTY BY WINNER
[inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS HUESO.
HI MITCHELL ARI [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI.
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
MEMBERS SOMEONE ASK YOU TO
PLEASE KEEP THE THE
CONVERSATIONS DOWN IF YOU WANT
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
PLEASE TAKE HIM OFF THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
OKAY
.
SENATORS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
AND RECOGNIZE SENATOR GROW.
Q. AND MADAM PRESIDENT I'D LIKE
TO LET EVERYBODY KNOW TODAY
TODAY IS A NATIONAL DAY OF
PRAYER.
AND I THINK IT'S FITTING THAT
JUST LAST NIGHT.
USE ME SAID ROTATING THAT JUST
LAST NIGHT WE ALL ATTENDED THE
SEDER DINNER IN THE RABBI CAME
UP AND HE WAS TALKING TO US AT
THE TABLE.
SAYING THAT HOW AT THE SCHOOLS
THEY INVOLUNTARILY SOME OF THESE
KIDS THAT HAVE ADHD IN A SPECIAL
SCHOOL THEY TAKE A MOMENT OF
SILENCE AND I KNOW THAT WHEN WE
HAVE THE SURE SRI LANKA ISSUE.
THE SENATE PRO TERROR THIS THE
PRESIDENT RUNNING THE SENATE
THAT DAY TOOK A MOMENT OF
SILENCE I KNOW THAT -- THERE IS
OFTEN TIMES THAT WE REFLECT IN
PRAYER FOR FAMILY THAT ARE ILL
AND I'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONSTITUENTS REACH OUT TO ME
TODAY AND JUST RECOGNIZE WE HAVE
SOME SEVERAL EVENTS REGARDING
THE NATIONAL DAY OF PRAYER TODAY
AND I KNOW THAT ALL OF US IN
THIS ROOM.
WE HAVE PER IN MY OFFICE AND I
KNOW OTHER PEOPLE HAVE PER IN
THEIR OFFICE. FOR US TO MANAGE
AND DO THE THINGS RIGHT FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I'M JUST
LETTING YOU KNOW TODAY IS
NATIONAL DAY OF PRAYER.
AND SO I JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO
PARTICIPATE IN THOSE THINGS IN
YOUR DISTRICT REGARDLESS OF WHAT
PRAYER YOU PARTICIPATE IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
CENTER GROVE.
WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THE
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
TEMPORARILY.
WILL MOVE ON TO AT THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE'RE ON THE SENATE THIRD
READING.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SENATOR PENN.
ARE YOU PREPARED PASS ON FILE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE SENATOR
GALGIANI.
PASS ON FILE -- AT AT THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS A PEACE OFFICER'S JOB IS
UNQUESTIONABLY ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT AND CHALLENGING IN OUR
SOCIETY TODAY.
THESE BRAVE OFFICERS ME OIL USE
ME SENATOR GALGIANI WE MUST READ
IT FIRST SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY FIVE A SENATOR GALGIANI
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS MEMORIAL DAY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AT PEACE OFFICERS JOB IS
UNQUESTIONABLY ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT AND CHALLENGING AND
OUR SOCIETY TODAY.
THESE BRAVE OFFICERS WORK
LOYALLY ON BEHALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF THE
DANGERS TO THEMSELVES.
THEY RISK GREAT PERIL SOMETIMES
RESULTING IN THE TRAGIC LOSS OF
THEIR LIFE AND SOMETIMES
RESULTING IN THE TRAGIC LIFE OF
ANOTHER.
S. C. R. TWENTY FIVE DESIGNATES
MONDAY MAY SIXTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AS CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS MEMORIAL DAY IN
COMMEMORATION OF THE COURAGEOUS
OFFICERS WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
LIVES IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
THIS IS THE FORTY THIRD YEAR
THAT CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE
STATE WILL COME TOGETHER TO SHOW
THEIR APPRECIATION TO OUR FALLEN
OFFICERS WE'RE TRULY INDEBTED TO
THEM AND THEIR SURVIVING
FAMILIES.
TODAY WE RECOGNIZE EIGHT
EXCEPTIONAL OFFICERS WHO LOST
THEIR LIVES LAST YEAR IN THE
LINE OF DUTY.
THIS INCLUDES DEPUTY STEVEN
BALLENGER LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
OFFICER GREGORY BECAUSE CS.
COME ON A POLICE DEPARTMENT.
DEPUTY RYAN DOUGLAS ZIRKLE.
MARIN COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE.
OFFICER KIRK CHRIS.
C. H. P. SOLANO AREA OFFICE.
DEPUTY MARK STARS JOKE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
SERGEANT RONALD HILLIS VENTURA
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE.
DEPUTY TONY HANNAH STROESSNER
STANISLAUS COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
CORPORAL RONALD SAYING.
NEWMAN POLICE DEPARTMENT.
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE TO ADDITIONAL
OFFICERS WHO WERE KILLED IN
DEFENSE OF THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
PRIOR YEARS BUT WE'RE NOT YET
ENROLLED IN THE PEACE OFFICERS
MEMORIAL.
DEBBIE TO HENRY SNOW ABOUT.
LAKE COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
DEPUTY MARSHAL MAURICE HALLORAN.
VERNON POLICE DEPARTMENT.
I KNOW THAT THIS IMPORTANT
MEMORIAL FOR THESE OFFICERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES STRIKES A CHORD.
WITH MANY OF YOU AS IT DOES FOR
ME.
SOME OF THESE MEN.
WERE FROM YOUR DISTRICTS.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE SHOWN YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
SURVIVING FAMILY MEMBERS BY CO
AUTHORING THIS RESOLUTION AND I
KNOW MANY OF YOU PLAN ON
ATTENDING THE ENROLLMENT
CEREMONY.
NEXT MONDAY.
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
SENDS A CLEAR MESSAGE OF RESPECT
AND ADMIRATION TO CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS PAST AND PRESENT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
SENATOR JIM NIELSEN.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE INDEED THIS
IS.
A WAR THE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT.
THE BRAVE INDIVIDUALS.
WHO PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE?
FOR ALL OF US.
WE'VE LOST A MANY THIS YEAR.
THE FOR SENATE DISTRICT DID.
AND THIS WAS BUT A YOUNG.
POLICE OFFICER IN DAVIS
CALIFORNIA.
ONLY ABOUT TWO WEEKS ON THE JOB.
AND SHE PAID.
THE ELEMENT PRICE.
IN OUR LIVES WHEN THINGS GET
TOUGH.
THEN WE DEPEND.
ON THESE FIRST RESPONDERS.
BOND FOR SPENT [inaudible]
FIRE PROTECTION.
AND THESE DAYS THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS SEEM
TO BE FAIR GAME TO BE MALIGNED
[inaudible]
AND CRITICIZED.
AND THINGS ARE DONE THAT MAKES
THEIR LIVES.
MORE AT RISK [inaudible]
MORE VULNERABLE.
WHEN I COME THE PEACE OFFICERS
MEMORIAL EACH YEAR?
CROSS STREETS OR WHEN I'M
WALKING OVER BY THE LIBRARY
COURTS BUILDING.
I GAZED AT THAT STATUTE.
OF A WOMAN.
WITH THE CHILDREN [inaudible]
GRIEVING.
OVER THE LOS [inaudible]
THE FATHER.
AND OF A HUSBAND.
WE ALL KNOW HOW.
THOSE WHO HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES
I'M SURE IN THE AREAS THAT WE
REPRESENT.
BECAUSE THESE LOSSES TO BECOME
ALL TOO FREQUENT NOW.
BUT REMEMBER THEY DO.
STAND ON THAT THEN BLUE LINE
[inaudible] FOR JUSTICE.
AND TO PROTECT US. ONE OF THE
SHERIFF'S THAT I'VE WORKED WITH.
WAS OFFERING ONE TIME.
AND THIS WAS RELATED TO ONE OF
OUR BIG CRISES OF LATE.
THE OROVILLE DAM FAILURE IN THIS
BILL WAY.
WELL HE WAS SENDING HIS
[inaudible]
DEPUTIES IN.
THE HARMS WAY.
DO WHATEVER COULD BE DONE. TO
GET THE CITIZENS OUT OF HARM'S
WAY [inaudible]
THEIR JOB.
WAS TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF HARM'S
WAY.
PONDER THE BURDEN ON THAT SHARE.
ORDERING THE PEOPLE UNDER HIS
AUTHORITY.
THE PUT THEIR LIVES DIRECTLY AT
RISK.
BY THE HUNDREDS. TO SAVE AND
PROTECT THE LIVES [inaudible]
THE THOUSANDS.
INDEED LET'S REMEMBER OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS
PARTICULARLY THESE DAYS
[inaudible]
SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I STAND BEFORE YOU TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF US SEE OUR TWENTY
FIVE OUR WORLD IS CERTAINLY
CHANGING WERE SAYING -- NEW
NORMAL IN MANY FACTORS OF LIFE
INCLUDING WILD FIRES AND
TERRORISM.
EVERY YEAR IT SEEMS LIKE RESCUE
MORE AND MORE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
MEN AND WOMEN WERE IN THE
DEFENSE OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR FAMILIES TO FACES GROWING
THREATS.
I'VE BEEN ELECTED OFFICIAL NOW
427- YEARS AND ONE OF THE MOST
DISTRESSING CALL SO WE GET AS
ELECTED OFFICIALS AS WHEN. ONE
OF THE MEMBERS ARE PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES.
IS MURDERED AND GUNNED DOWN.
IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE ALL I
WAS MAYOR OF THE CITY TO MACULA
WE HAD OUR FIRST POLICE OFFICER
KILLED IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
MR CAN'T IN REGARD.
WHO IS RESPONDING TO ONE OF THE
MOST DANGEROUS TYPES OF CALLS
THAT THEY RESPOND?
TO A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CALL
[inaudible]
MR HANDGUARD.
UP APPREHENDED THE SUSPECT.
HE SAID HE NEEDED TO GET A FEW
THINGS OUT OF HIS TRUCK TO TAKE
WITH THEM TO JAIL.
UNBEKNOWNST TO THE NEW OFFICER.
HE PULLED OUT A SHOT GUN.
AND KILL HIM IN COLD BLOOD.
WE NIGHT AT THE PEACE OFFICERS
MEMORIAL TO MEMORIALIZE THOSE
OFFICERS WHO HAVE BEEN KILLED IN
THE LINE OF DUTY THROUGHOUT.
CALIFORNIA MEN.
AND WOMEN.
WHEN A POLICE OFFICER OR PEACE
OFFICER LEAVES THEIR HOME EVERY
MORNING?
THE KISS OUR SPOUSE IN THEIR
KIDS GOOD BYE [inaudible]
NOT KNOWING.
IF IT WILL BE THE LAST TIME.
OF THEM DOING SO.
EVERY DAY PEACE OFFICERS PUT
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE TO
PROTECT THEIR FAMILIES THEIR
FRIENDS.
ARE CONSTITUENTS YOU
[inaudible]
AND ME.
THANK YOU TO THE SENATOR FOR
STOCKTON. FOR BRINGING ESSIE OUR
TWENTY FIVE FORD.
I WILL BE VOTING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION ENCOURAGE ALL OF
YOU TO DO THE SAME.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS WELL THE
RESOLUTION RATHER.
AS YOU KNOW I'VE SHARED WITH
MARBLE POLICE DEPARTMENT HEAD I
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT I HAVE BEEN
THERE.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN WHEN MY
FELLOW OFFICERS RESPONDED
[inaudible]
AND EACH AND EVERY TIME THEY
RESPOND.
WITH DUTY WITH WATER WITH
DIGNITY.
AND A SENSE OF PRIDE IN THE
SERVICE THEY GIVE TO THEIR
COMMUNITY.
AND ACROSS THIS NATION ACROSS
THIS GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WE SEE BRAVERY EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WOULD MEN AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM
WILL PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE.
AND TODAY WE'RE A KNOWLEDGE IN
THOSE WHO HAVE GIVEN THEIR LIVES.
BUT I ALSO MUST POINT OUT THAT
THOSE WHO'VE RETIRED.
ARE FALLING APART BECAUSE OF
THEIR WORK THE STRESS.
IN IN THE CITY OF MONTEBELLO WE
JUST LOST.
A VERY GOOD OFFICER LIEUTENANT
THAT I SHARED WITH THE TENANT
ADACHI.
AND I CAN'T UNDERSTAND WELL HE'S
SO YOUNG.
BUT HE ALSO LOST HIS LIFE TO
CANCER IT HAPPENS TO OUR
FIREFIGHTERS IT HAPPENS TO OUR
POLICE OFFICERS.
SO AFTER YEARS AND YEARS OF
SERVICE THEIR LIVES ARE
SHORTENED.
BUT THOSE HAVE GIVEN THEIR LIVES
IN THE LINE OF DUTY WE
ACKNOWLEDGE TODAY AND I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR RESOLUTION I STAND.
HIS SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT I TOO WOULD LIKE TO
STAND IN SUPPORT OF S. C. R..
TWENTY FIVE AND IT KNOWLEDGE TO
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO HAVE
COMMITTED THEIR LIVES TO PROTECT
AND SERVE ALL -- WITH FALLEN IN
THE LINE OF DUTY.
I THINK IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US
AS PUBLIC SERVICE THE NOT ONLY
MEMORIALIZE THOSE WHO HAVE
FALLEN BUT TO PLEDGE OUR
COMMITMENT ON AN ONGOING BASIS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE MEN AND
WOMEN OF BLUE.
HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY NEED FOR
APPROPRIATE TRAINING.
MEANT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
APPROPRIATE HEALTH SERVICES AND
PENSIONS THAT RESPECT AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE VALUE THAT THEY
SERVE.
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS FOR
THAT AND MANY OTHER REASONS I
AGAINST THEM IN SUPPORT OF S. C.
R..
TWENTY FIVE SENATOR GALGIANI YOU
MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VITAL.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SAYING NO OBJECTION.
I THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS.
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
AND IT WILL BE IMMEDIATELY
TRANSMITTED TO THE ASSEMBLY AS
REQUESTED.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY TWO SENATOR RUBIO.
ARE YOU PREPARED.
PASS ON FILE.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE SENATOR
PAN.
PASS ON FILE.
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
TWENTY FOUR SENATOR LEYVA.
PASS ON FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE SENATOR PAN.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FORTY THREE BY SENATOR PAN
ENACT GOING TO GENERAL
GOVERNMENT PROVISIONS.
NOW THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS ARE
FAMILY OWNED BUSINESSES HAD
UNIQUE CHARACTERISTICS HOWEVER
THERE IS NO STANDARDIZED
DEFINITION OF A FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESS.
A STANDARD DEFINITION ACROSS
STATE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WILL
ALLOW POLICYMAKERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REFERENCE ONE
DEFINITION ACROSS YOUR DICKS
JURISDICTIONS IN CODES THIS
POLICIES ARE CONSIDERED.
THE ABSENCE OF UNIFORMED
DEFINITION LEAVES POLICYMAKERS
WITHOUT ACCURATE DATA ON
IMPLEMENTING POLICY ISSUES SUCH
AS TAX IN THE STATE'S SUCCESSION.
SB FORTY THREE WILL TO FIND
CALIFORNIA FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESSES AS BUSINESSES
DOMICILED IN CALIFORNIA IN
OPERATION FOR TEN YEARS OR MORE
OWNED AND CONTROLLED BY RELATED
PERSONS OR PARTNERSHIP OF
RELATED PERSONS THAT PASSED.
THE BUSINESS THROUGH A
GENERATION OR HAVE A PLAN FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS SUCCESSION
THIS BILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA LEAD
THE NATION BY BEING THE FIRST
ACTUALLY TO FIND A FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
CENTER PAN YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
ESPECIALLY YES OR NO VOTE.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ON THIS ITEM.
SAYING NO OBJECTION.
I THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS.
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible] FOR SENATORS ARE
GOING RETURN TO PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR [inaudible]
AND CALL ON SENATOR ARCHULETA.
AT THE PRO TEM'S DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT CAN
MEMBERS I HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST.
TODAY MANY SCHEDULE BEST WITH
THE I THINK YOU WILL ALL
RECOGNIZE THEM.
LATER INTO THE DAY THERE
VISITING US FROM FAR FAR AWAY.
I AM PROUD TO RECOGNIZE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S GARRISON FIVE OH
FIRST.
THE FIVE OFFERS IS AN ALL
VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATION THAT IS
INVOLVED IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE NATION
AND INDEED THE GALAXY.
BRING STAR WARS FANS THEMSELVES.
ALL OF US HAVE SEEN THE MOVIE
UNDERSTAND WHAT STAR WARS S ALL
ABOUT FAMILY BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER TRADITION.
THEYHAVE CREATED BEAUTIFULLY
DESIGNED COSTUMES INSPIRED BY
THE CLONE AND STORM TROOPERS
FROM THE MOVIES AND EXPANDED
UNIVERSE.
BUT THESE FOLKS TO MORE THAN
ATTENDED MOVIES AND PREMIERES.
ONE OF THEM AND WHAT OTHER
PILLARS IT'S ALWAYS BEEN TO COME
TOGETHER TO BE TO DO WORK
CHARITABLE WORK FOR THE
COMMUNITIES.
AND I'M SO PROUD THAT THE FIGHT
WILL FIRST.
HAVE REPORTED AND THEY'VE LOGGED
IN HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
HOURS OF VOLUNTEER WORK.
APPEARING AT A CHARITY EVENTS
STORMING THE HALLS OF OF ROOMS
OF PATIENTS IN HOSPITALS
THROUGHOUT.
THE COUNTY AND STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THEY DO NOT ACCEPT COMPENSATION
FOR THEIR WORK AND THEIR
APPEARANCES INSTEAD THEY INSIST
ON DONATIONS TO BE MADE IN THEIR
NAMES.
AND FOR CHARITY.
SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN CLOSE TO
ONE MILLION DOLLARS HAVE BEEN
DONATED IN THE NAME OF THE FIVE
WILL FIRST.
THEY ARE BRIGHT.
AND THEY ARE A BRIGHT LIGHT
HOWEVER THEY MUST BE -- SHARED
WHAT THEY DO IT'S SO IMPORTANT
THAT THEY LIGHT UP THE LIGHTS OF
THE KIDS THAT THEY SEE AND I'VE
HEARD THE STORY TIME AND TIME
AGAIN.
WHEN THEY WALK INTO THE HOSPITAL
THESE KIDS JUST RUN IN THE DOOR --
THEY HUG HIM AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE TEARS UNDERNEATH THE
MAX JUST KEEP FALLING.
THEY ARE ARE VERY FORTUNATE THEY
TELL ME BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
THEY GIVE SO MUCH AND RECEIVE
EVEN MORE BACK.
THE RESOLUTION TODAY I'M HAPPY
TO RESENT.
IS TO RECOGNIZE MAY FOURTH AS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GARRISON DAY
AND I'M PROUD TO HAVE THEM HERE
WITH ME.
SO I AM ASKING THAT IF THE THERE
RIGHT BEHIND ME HERE -- ROB
STILL MARK WOULD YOU PLEASE STEP
FORWARD. FOR ONE SECOND.
JASON C. SO.
NICK SENSE NAVALI.
RALLY CAN A LOT SAM NEWCOMER.
AND MICHELLE NEWCOMER.
AND UPON A GERMAN TODAY.
MY COLLEAGUES YOU WILL BE ABLE
TO COME TO ROOM.
TWO ELEVEN AND SEE THEM ALL
DECKED OUT IN THE STAR WARS
COSTUMES.
SO I URGE YOU TO PLEASE COME BY
AFTER SESSION THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GATHERED GARRISON
STRETCHES ALL ACROSS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PART TO THE STATE.
COVERING MANY MANY OF YOUR
DISTRICT.
AND I AM SURE THAT YOU'VE SEEN
THEM ON TV THEY ARE HERE BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT THEY'VE GIVEN
SO MUCH AND I THINK IT'S TIME TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ON YOUR BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE GOOD WORK
THAT YOU DO AND PLEASE REMEMBER.
MAY.
AND MAY THE FORCE BE WITH YOU.
PLEASE RISE [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
A BIG SENATE WELCOME TO THE FIVE
OH FIRST.
REGION OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AND FOR YOUR CONTRIBUTIONS TO
CHARITY [inaudible]
THEY CAME.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX ON THE
FILE SENATOR SKINNER.
YOU'RE PREPARED.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY FOUR BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND ACT REALLY
INTO CRIMINAL PROCEDURE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB THREE NINETY FOUR
CREATES THE OPTION OF A
DIVERSION COURT. FOR PRIMARY
CARE GIVERS OF DEPENDENT
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN NOW.
IN ORDER FOR THIS DIVERSION
COURT FOR A DEFENDANT TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS DIVERSION COURT.
THE PRESIDING JUDGE THE DA AND
THE PUBLIC DEFENDER ALL HAVE TO
A DEGREE.
I AGREE [inaudible]
ADDITIONALLY DEFENDANTS CHARGED
WITH SERIOUS AND VIOLENT
FELONIES ARE EXCLUDED.
FROM BEING ABLE TO ACCESS.
THIS DIVERSION COURT IF.
WE ARE IF IT IS ESTABLISHED THAT
IS IN THE BILL.
KNOW WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF
THREE NINETY FOUR ITS PURPOSE IS
TO RECOGNIZE.
THAT FAMILY SEPARATION HAS
SIRIUS AND SOMETIMES PERMANENT
IMPACTS.
ON THE PARENT AND THE CHILD
IMPACTED WE HEARD VERY VERY
POWERFUL TESTIMONY IN THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE FROM A MOTHER
AND HER DAUGHTER.
THE MOTHER ASHLEY WAS CHARGED IN
PRIOR TO HER TRIAL.
SHE TOOK HER THE FACT THAT SHE
WAS IN THIS SERIOUS SITUATION
QUITE SERIOUSLY AT THE POINT OF
HER.
BEING CHARGED SHE HAD.
A CHILD WHO WAS A TODDLER.
IN PRIOR TO THE TRIAL.
SHE SECURED EMPLOYMENT.
SHE ATTENDED VOCATIONAL TRAINING
IN PARENTING CLASSES AND SHE
DEMONSTRABLY TURNED HER LIFE
AROUND BY THE TIME OF HER TRIAL.
THERE WERE POLICE OFFICERS
COMMUNITY LEADERS AND MANY
OTHERS WHO TESTIFIED TO HER
CHARACTER INTO THE CLEAR
DEPARTURE FROM THE BEHAVIOR THAT
SHE HAD EXHIBITED.
THAT LED TO THE CHARGE.
BUT GIVEN THAT THERE WERE NO
DIVERSION COURT OPTIONS.
SHE WAS SENTENCED AND SERVED
THREE YEARS AT THE POINT THAT
SHE STARTED HER INCARCERATION.
HER DAUGHTER WAS THREE YEARS OLD.
AT THE POINT THAT SHE WAS
REUNITED WITH HER FAMILY AND HER
DAUGHTER.
THE DAUGHTER DIDN'T REALLY EVEN
KNOW HER NOR DID ACTUALLY KNOW
HER CHILD.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING
WITH THAT DETACHMENT SINCE THAT
TIME IN HER DAUGHTER ASIA
TESTIFIED TO COMMITTEE.
IT WAS VERY VERY POWERFUL NOW
CLEARLY SUCH A DIVERSION COURT
IS NOT APPROPRIATE FOR ALL
DEFENDANTS AND THAT IS WHY THE
BILL IS DESIGNED NUMBER ONE TO
EXCLUDE THOSE WITH SERIOUS AND
VIOLENT FELONIES.
AND ADDITIONALLY TO REQUIRE THE
PRESIDING JUDGE THE DA AND THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER TO ALL AGREE
BEFORE THAT DEFENDANT CAN HAVE
THAT OPTION FOR DIVERSION COURT.
AND WITH THAT I ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT SB.
THREE NINETY FOUR IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
SENATOR GROVE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
ARE YOU PREPARED TO ACCEPT
QUESTION YES.
SO I A CAN ADDRESS IT IN YOUR
CLOTHES IF YOU LIKE BECAUSE THEY
REALIZE THERE'S NO DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR BUT I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS I'D LIKE CLARIFIED --
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS --
PROGRAM IS MODELED AFTER THE
VETERANS COURT THAT'S BEEN
SUCCESSFUL I NEED TO KNOW IF
THAT'S TRUE OR NOT.
AND IN THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY THE
PROBE -- THE PUBLIC DEFENDER AND
THE JUDGE HAVE I DON'T SEE VETO
POWER BUT THEY HAVE SOME THEY
CAN OBJECT TO SOMEONE.
GOING THROUGH THIS PROCESS IF
THEY FEEL THAT THIS PERSON IS A
THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY OR IF
THERE IS ANOTHER ISSUE THAT THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S FILL THAT --
THIS THE PERSON THAT IS IN
QUESTION DOES NOT MEET THE
QUALIFICATIONS OF THE PROGRAM.
AND NUMBER THREE AND I HATE THAT
THERE'S THREE BUT IT IS.
IF THEY GO THROUGH THIS
DIVERSION PROGRAM AND THEY DO
NOT SUCCESSFULLY STAY ON THE
PROGRAM COMPLETE ALL THE CLASSES
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO MAKE THEM.
OF OF A BETTER MEMBER OF SOCIETY
LIKE JOBS AND YOU KNOW THINGS
THAT ARE IN THE PROGRAM FOR
DIVERSION.
IF IF THAT DOES NOT HAPPEN IS
CAN THEY GO BACK TO TRIAL OR IS
IT DISMISSED YEAH I NEED TO KNOW
IF IT'S DISMISSED WITH OR
WITHOUT PREJUDICE.
SO IF YOU COULD ANSWER THAT THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL I REALLY
APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD IS THERE ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING NINE FIVE CENTER SKINNER
YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU -- FOR
ARE.
MINORITY LEADER SCHOOL QUESTIONS
WHICH I WILL ADDRESS IN THIS
CLOSE SO AS I INDICATED IN MY
OPENING.
THIS DIVERSION COURT IF WE WERE
TO ESTABLISH IT.
WOULD NOT BE AVAILABLE TO A
DEFENDANT ON LESS.
ALL.
THREE THE JUDGE.
THE DA.
AND THE PUBLIC DEFENDER AGREE
AND THEY HAVE TO AGREE IN
WRITING.
THAT'S EXPLICIT IN THE BILL
[inaudible]
AND THE PROGRAM IS MODELED AFTER
ARE VERY SUCCESSFUL VETERANS
DIVERSION COURT WHICH WE
RECOGNIZED IN ESTABLISHING IT WE
RECOGNIZED THAT OUR VETERANS.
COME BACK [inaudible]
AND THEY'VE SUFFERED GREAT
TRAUMA FROM THEIR EXPERIENCES IN
OUR IN THEIR SERVICE ON OUR
BEHALF.
AND WE NOT ONLY HAVE THEY
SUFFERED THIS DRAMA THEY'VE ALSO
UNFORTUNATELY ARE EXPERIENCING
SIGNIFICANT DELAYS IN THEIR
ABILITY TO ACCESS.
THERE THE SERVICES THAT ARE
VETERANS DEPARTMENT WOULD OFFER
THEM.
SO NOW DOES THAT JUSTIFY ANY
TYPE OF CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR NO BUT
IT CERTAINLY WE WE HAVE
UNDERSTOOD THAT IT CAN LEAD A
PERSON TO BEHAVIORS THAT.
WE DON'T FIND ACCEPTABLE BUT
THAT WE HAVE WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO FACTOR THOSE THINGS.
BEFORE WE SENTENCE THEM AARON TO
INCARCERATE THEM AND SO THAT'S
WHY WE ESTABLISH THE VETERANS
COURT.
AND BY ALL ACCOUNTS IT IS
WORKING VERY VERY WELL.
AND WE HAVE NOT SEEN A TERRIBLE
UPTICK IN THOSE VETERANS WHO
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE DIVERSIONARY COURT.
IN THERE ARE. FIVE ONCE THEY
HAVE BEEN GIVEN THIS OPTION AND
HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE TYPE ACOSTA
THE AVAILABLE TO THEM -- AND
CERTAINLY THESE DO YOU.
THE OTHER PART OF IT IS THAT IN
A DIVERSION COURT IT IS THE THE
ENTITIES THAT ARE PART OF THAT
pSUCH THATDETERMINE THEN WHAT
ARE THE OPTIONS IF THE PERSON IS
NOT INCARCERATED.
SO DOES INCLUDE ELECTRONIC
MONITORING IS IT SUCH IS THE
WHAT OTHER TYPES OF SUPERVISION
IS THE PERSON PUT IN IN ORDER TO
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND SO WE'VE SEEN IT WORKED VERY
WELL IN THE VETERANS
DIVERSIONARY COURT IN SO YES
THIS IS PATTERNED AFTER THAT.
NOW TO THE QUESTION OF IF THE
PERSON.
IS BREAKS ANY OF THE IF YOU KNOW
IF THEY VIOLATE ANY OF THE TERMS
OF THE SUPERVISION.
THEN YES THEY WOULD BE BROUGHT
BACK THAT IS ALSO PART OF THE
BILL IT IT THEY WOULDN'T THERE
THIS IS NOT A GET OUT OF JAIL
FREE CARD.
SO I HOPE THAT I ADDRESSED THE
CONCERNS THAT ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES MIGHT HAVE.
AND THIS IS THE SERIOUS FELONIES.
SERIOUS VIOLENT FELONY SUCH AS
MURDER AND RAPE AND OF COURSE
MANY OTHERS AND I DON'T MEAN
ONLY TO BRING UP THOSE BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE OTHER
SERIOUS -- IN VIOLENT FELONIES
THAT ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE
DEFENDANT BEING ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS PROGRAM.
SO THIS IS REALLY ABOUT TRYING
TO ENSURE THAT WE IF THERE IS A
CLEAR PATH. FOR A PERSONAGE
DEMONSTRATED THEIR
REHABILITATIVE.
POTENTIAL AND WE CAN KEEP A
FAMILY FROM BEING SEPARATED AND
THUS A CHILD FROM GOING INTO
FOSTER CARE FOR EXAMPLE.
THIS IS ONE OPTION THAT WE MIGHT
HAVE TO PURSUE AND WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB.
THREE NINETY FOUR THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
BY BILL BY PORGES.
BY BRADFORD.
BY COUNTY AT ALL HI I CHIANG
[inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
BY HILL AYE HUESO.
BY HER TITLE.
I JACKSON BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
I MONEY BY MORE LOCK.
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PAN.
HI PORTANTINO.
BY ROSS.
BY RUBIO.
HI SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
HI MY COUNTY.
HI WINNER BY WILK.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
WILK.
ICE THIRTY KNOWS TO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER --
TWENTY SEVEN SENATOR WESO.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THREE THIRTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR HUESO AN ACT RELATING TO
ELDER INDEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- I
AM VERY PROUD TO PRESENT SB
THREE THREE EIGHT A BILL WHICH
SEEKS TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS FROM
HARM AND ABUSE.
SB THREE THREE A WILL CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR AND DISABILITY
JUSTICE ACT.
WHICH WILL GIVE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TOOLS TO
BETTER PROTECT.
SENIOR CITIZENS AND CALIFORNIA'S
LOOK CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES.
FROM ABUSE SEXUAL ASSAULT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HATE CRIMES
AND MURDER.
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS AND HE
WILL COUNTY SAW A 37% INCREASE
IN CRIMES AGAINST SENIORS.
FORTUNATELY IN RESPONSE TO THIS
DRAMATIC INCREASE THANK YOU WILL
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
OF THIS SUMMER STEPHAN CONVENED
EXPERT PROFESSIONALS FROM ALL
DISCIPLINES THAT SERVE AS TOUCH
POINTS FOR ELDER INDEPENDENT
ADULTS.
THOSE EXPERTS IDENTIFIED GAPS
AND NEEDS IN THE SANDY WILL
COMMUNITY AND SET GOALS FOR THE
FUTURE.
WHICH RESULTED IN THE CREATION
OF A COMPREHENSIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT GUIDE KNOWN AS THE
BLUEPRINT.
THIS BILL ADOPTS MANY OF THE
BILL BLUEPRINTS FINDINGS AND FOR
THE FIRST TIME ANYWHERE THIS
BILL IS ALL CALIFORNIA LAWS
SPECIFICALLY.
PROTECTING SENIORS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES INCLUDING
BROADER.
MAJOR LAWS ARE SPECIFICALLY
AFFECT THOSE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
EVERY CITY POLICE DEPARTMENT
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT THAT
ADOPTS OR REVISE IS AN OLDER
ELDER INDEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE
POLICY.
WILL BE REQUIRED TO ADOPT THE
POLICY INFORMING OFFICERS OF
THESE LAWS AND GUIDING THEM ON
HOW TO RESPOND TO THESE CRIMES.
SB THREE THREE IT HAS RISEN.
AS HAS RECEIVED NO NAY VOTES AND
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION IS
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
OF ORGANIZATIONS WHICH INCLUDE
THE SENATE WITH DISTRICT
ATTORNEY.
THE ELDER AND HEALTH LAW CLINIC
OF THEM MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF LAW.
THE ARC OF SAN DIEGO IN THE
UNITED SOBRE CEREBRAL CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION.
I ALSO THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
OF RETIRED AMERICANS AND MANY
MORE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
ANY OBJECTION TO THIS BEING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NO OBJECTION FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZEROS THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM.
NUMBER [inaudible]
TWENTY EIGHT SENATOR WESSEL.
PASS ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
TWENTY NINE SENATOR PORTANTINO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FOR EIGHTEEN BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
RELATING TO THE PAYMENT OF
CLAIMS AGAINST THE STATE MAKING
PURPOSE THEIR FOREIGN CLEARING
THEIR THROAT TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
OR IS YOURS MISTER PORTANTINO
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OF
MEMBERS.
SB FOUR EIGHTEEN IS ONE OF THE
BILL'S CARRIED BY THE CHAIRS IN
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
EACH YEAR. TO PROVIDE PAYMENT
AUTHORITY FOR LEGAL CLAIMS
APPROVED BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FINANCE.
THIS URGENCY MEASURE APPROPRIATE
TO APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO PAY THE FOLLOWING CLAIMS.
MALIGN OVER SHOULD CHIANG
ABSTAIN VERSE SCHWARZENEGGER --
SUBROGATION CLAIM BY THIRTY
EIGHT INSURANCE COMPANIES
RELATED TO THE SKIN FIRE AND
FORTY FIVE INDIVIDUALS --
GOVERNMENT CLAIM FOR DAMAGES AS
A RESULT OF THE SKIN FILE THESE
CLAIMS ARE TIME SENSITIVE AND
BOTH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AGREE
THAT PAYMENT IS IN THE STATE'S
BEST INTERESTS.
THE BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT -- THUS FAR I IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
SEEING NONE [inaudible]
MISTER SECRETARY [inaudible]
UP WITH.
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES.
I BRADFORD
I COUNTY AT ALL HI BY CHIANG
[inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
AYE HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI FI FOR TITLE.
BY JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK.
I'M RAIL.
BY NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE.
IOWA CASKEY.
WIENER.
HI WILK [inaudible]
HI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BY KATHY
[inaudible]
HI.
I THIRTY EIGHT NO ZEROS ON THE
URGENCY I THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
ZERO ON THE BILL THE BILL PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER -- THIRTY PASS ON
FILE.
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
THIRTY ONE SENATOR MCGUIRE.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
REQUIRE AN ACCOLADE ELECTIONS A
DECLINE THEIR THROATS TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
CENTER MCGUIRE HEY GOOD MORNING
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH -- HONORED TO BE HERE TO
PRESENT THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF
THE SENATOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
IT'S TE PRESIDENTIAL
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT.
MEMBERS I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT TRANSPARENCY IS A NON
PARTISAN ISSUE IN ITS THAT
TRANSPARENCY THAT PROVIDES THE
BASIS FOR ACCOUNTABILITY IN
GOVERNMENT. FOR THE PAST FORTY
YEARS MEMBERS EVERY U. S.
PRESIDENT REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS ALIKE HAVE RELEASED
THEIR TAX RETURNS.
THESE PATRIOTS HAVE PUT THEIR
NATION'S INTERESTS ABOVE
EVERYTHING ELSE PRESIDENTS ARE
EXPECTED TO BE TO PUT THEIR OWN
INTERESTS DECIDE WHETHER IT BE
BUSINESS TIES OUR RELATIONSHIPS
WITH A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT. FOR
THE GREATER GOOD OF OUR NATION
AND THAT GREATER GOOD IS
AMERICAN SECURITY IN THE
PROTECTION OF ITS PEOPLE.
INCOME TAX RETURNS FOR
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES PROVIDE
VOTERS WITH ESSENTIAL
INFORMATION.
ON REGARDING POTENTIAL CONFLICTS
OF INTEREST DOMESTIC AND
INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS DEALINGS
FINANCIAL STATUS IS IN
CHARITABLE DONATIONS.
AND WHILE THE RELEASING OF TAX
RETURNS HAS SPARKED INTENSE
CONVERSATION AND DEBATE OVER THE
PAST MANY DECADES ALL CANDIDATES
ALL CANDIDATES HAVE PUT THE
DISCOMFORT ASIDE FOR THE PAST
FOUR DECADES BECAUSE THE
RELEASING OF TAX RETURNS.
HAS BECOME A TIME HONORED
TRADITION IN OUR DEMOCRACY
[inaudible]
NOW.
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SAY THIS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A STRONG
EXAMPLE THE NEED FOR THIS
LEGISLATION BUT HE'S NOT THE
ONLY.
ONE THIS BILL IS ABOUT IS NOT
ABOUT ONE SPECIFIC PERSON OR
POLITICAL PARTY IT'S MUCH BIGGER
THAN ACT.
AND I WOULD BE HERE SPEAKING ON
THIS FLOOR TODAY IF HILLARY
CLINTON HAD NOT RELEASED HER TAX
RETURNS.
STATES HAVE AN ESSENTIAL ROLE IN
PROVIDING CHECKS AND BALANCES TO
FEDERAL POLICY IN FACT BY THE
POWER OF THE US CONSTITUTION
STATES HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DETERMINE.
THAT THE BALLOT ACCESS
REQUIREMENTS VOTERS NOT ONLY
DESERVE FULL DISCLOSURE OF THEIR
FUTURE LEADERS TAX RETURNS THEY
SHOULD BE ENTITLED.
AND THIS LEGISLATION WILL HELP
BRING THAT TRANSPARENCY BACK.
SB ONE FORTY NINE IS SUPPORTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA SECRETARY OF
STATE IN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM [inaudible]
SENATOR WIENER.
I THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT WANTED TO BE A JOINT
AUTHORED THIS BILL INTO A
PARTNERED WITH -- THE SENATOR
FROM HEALDSBURG ON AND I WANT TO
THANK HIM FOR HIS LEADERSHIP --
THIS IS BASIC TRANSPARENCY
HAVING A LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT
THAT IT WAS ALREADY LEGALLY
REQUIRED FOR PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES.
TO DISCLOSE THEIR TAX RETURNS
BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH A ROUTINE
THING AND EVERYONE DID IT -- AND
PEOPLE REALLY SHOCKED TO LEARN
THAT IT'S NOT REQUIRED AND WE
NEED TO MAKE A REQUIRED AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
SENATOR BURGESS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
WASN'T PLANNING ON SPEAKING ON
THIS MATTER -- THE IT HAD GONE
TO JUDICIARY AND I WANT TO
COMMEND -- THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL FOR BEING A MAN OF HIS WORD
AND CONTINUING -- TO TO HAVE THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT BEGAN IN
JUDICIARY -- I HAD EXPRESSED US
OPPOSITION AT THAT POINT --
PRIMARILY BECAUSE I THINK WE
SHOULD TREAT OUR FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR OUR REGION WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR FEDERAL
OFFICERS.
ARE THE SAME AS OUR STATE
OFFICERS AND VICE VERSA SO I
THINK FOR CREDIBILITY PURPOSES
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL THAT IF
ANYTHING LIKE THIS WERE TO GO
FORWARD.
THAT THERE BE AN EVEN PLAYING
FIELD I DON'T THINK THIS
SCRUTINY SHOULD BE MUCH HIGHER --
UNDER THE PRESENT CIRCUMSTANCES
SO AS A MATTER POLICY -- I HAD
PRESENTED THAT JUDICIARY -- AND
I I THINK -- WILL BE HEARING
ABOUT THIS IN THE IN THE FUTURE
I WILL -- RESPECTFULLY.
DECLINE -- TO SUPPORT THIS AT
THIS POINT BUT THOSE ARE MY
SENTIMENTS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
CENTER JONES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS --
NONPARTISAN STATEMENT THAT HE
WOULD BE SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF
THE PROPOSAL REGARDLESS OF THE
NOMINEE EVEN IF HILLARY CLINTON
HAD NOT SHARED HER -- TAX
RETURNS I WOULD ALSO BE SPEAKING
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL --
REGARDLESS OF THE PRESIDENTIAL
NOMINEE ORTHEIR DESIRE TO
RELEASE ARE NOT RELEASE THEIR
TAX RETURNS.
I HAD INITIALLY OFFERED
AMENDMENTS -- DRAFTED -- TO TO
EXPAND THIS MAJOR TO ALL
CANDIDATES FOR FEDERAL OFFICE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT WOULD BE PEOPLE RUNNING FOR
U. S. HOUSE SEATS AND OUR TWO U.
S. SENATE SEATS.
MY THOUGHT WAS THE AS IN YOUR
BOARD JUST MENTION THAT WHAT IS
GOOD FOR THE GOOSE IS ALSO GOOD
FOR THE GANDER.
AFTER ALL THE SECOND IN LINE OF
SUCCESSION TO THE PRESIDENT.
IS CURRENTLY THE HOUSE A HOUSE
MEMBER FROM CALIFORNIA SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI.
AND THE THIRD IN LINE OF
SUCCESSION TO TO THE HOUSE THAT
U. S. SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM.
WALL CURRENTLY THAT OFFICES HELP
AND I'M CERTAINLY BACK UP.
THIRD IN LINE OF SUCCESSION IS
THAT HOW YOU S. SENATE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM.
AND WHILE THAT CURRENTLY THAT
OFFICE IS CURRENTLY HELD BY A
SENATOR FROM IOWA.
IT S POSSIBLE ONE DAY THAT IT
COULD BE HELD FROM A SENATOR
FROM CALIFORNIA.
ANYWAY LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
OPINED THAT MY MEMBERS JUST BE
TWENTY SEVEN WOULD MOST LIKELY
VIOLATE THE U. S. CONSTITUTION.
SO I'M NOT GOING TO OFFER THOSE
AMENDMENTS TODAY HAS I DON'T
WANT TO WASTE ANY OF OUR TIME.
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL HAS IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD ALSO OPINED THAT SB
TWENTY SEVEN ITSELF.
VIOLATES THE US CONSTITUTION.
FORMER GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN IS
BEACH HAS VETOED THE PREDECESSOR
TO SB TWENTY SEVEN LAST SESSION
EVEN SAID THAT THE BILL PROBABLY
WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
I GET THAT PLAYING THE
RESISTANCE CARD MAY BE GOOD
POLITICS FOR THE MAJORITY PARTY.
BUT I WOULD SUBMIT THAT IT'S BAD
POLICY FOR CALIFORNIANS.
THE MAJORITY PARTY SOLVES ALL
THE REAL PROBLEMS FACING OUR%
STATE SUCH AS A HIGH GASOLINE
TAX COSTS.
LACK OF HOUSING RAMPANT
HOMELESSNESS GRIDLOCK TRAFFIC
HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT.
GAINES INVIOLATE CRIME THEN I'D
RECOMMEND STOP PLAYING POLITICS
AND LET'S START GOVERNING.
I I RECOMMEND A NO VOTE ON THIS
MAJOR THANK YOU.
SENATOR BREAUX.
THANK YOU MEMBERS -- COUPLE OF
HIS THOUGHTS THAT I HAD -- I I
THINK MAYBE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
OUR CURRENT PRESIDENT WHO HAS
BEEN AUDIT OF FIFTEEN OR SIXTEEN
YEARS IN A ROW.
AND HAS BEEN FOUND -- HIS TAXES
ARE CLEAN BUT BUT THAT'S NOT THE
DISCUSSION WHERE I WANT TO GO I
THINK ABOUT IF THIS COMES DOWN
TO US ON THE FLOOR I'VE SPOKEN
TO A NUMBER OF PEOPLE HERE WHO
OWN RENTAL PROPERTIES RIGHT.
IN ON YUR SCHEDULE II IT HAS
YOU KNOW YOUR ADDRESS HERE
RENTAL PROPERTIES RIGHT SO LET'S
SAY YOU HAVE SOMEBODY.
THAT WANTS TO HARM YOU -- THEY
COULD GO TO YOUR RENTAL PROPERTY
AND HARM YOUR TENANTS FOR AN
EXAMPLE MILLER'S THAT'S PERSONAL
INFORMATION IT'S GONNA INFECT
YOUR TENANTS AND OTHER THINGS.
AS WELL AS EVEN WHAT YOUR
INVESTMENTS ARE EVEN MAYBE
COMPANIES IT YOUR OWN SELF
HABITAT -- PERSONAL AND PRIVATE
INFORMATION -- FOR LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS OUT THERE FOR EVERYBODY
SEE I THINK -- COULD CAUSE A LOT
OF PROBLEMS FOR FOR ALL OF US
HERE IF WE END UP BY -- YOU KNOW
HOW HOW DOES THE SAYING GO
OPPORTUNITY ERA.
OPPORTUNITY FOR í
FAVORITISM TOWARDS NINE SO IF
YOU BELIEVE IN AT THAT PERHAPS
WE SHOULD EXTEND OUT TO EVERYONE
HERE TOO SO I WILL BE A NO VOTE
ON IT BECAUSE I THINK -- IT'S
NOT GREAT POLICY BUT I LOVE THE
AUTHOR [inaudible]
SENATOR ALAN.
AND THE QUESTION TO THE OTHER.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO ACCEPT
QUESTION ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
MAY PROCEED SENATE WE WERE JUST
TALKING HERE ABOUT -- THE ISSUE
OF CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTIONS AND
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THOSE WOULD
HAVE TO BE DISCLOSED.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT AND
BECAUSE THAT THAT COULD THAT
COULD BE BE A PRETTY INVASIVE
[inaudible]
POTENTIALLY.
WHEN WE ARE IN COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH RIGHT TO THE GOOD
CENTER -- WE'RE COMMITTEE WE
ACTUALLY SHOWED TO REDACTED
VERSIONS ONE FROM A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH AND ONE
FROM A DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT
BARACK OBAMA.
I IN SENSITIVE INFORMATION IS
REDACTED.
REDACTED BY THE FEDS -- AND THEN
PUT ONLINE -- AND WE WERE ABLE
TO BE ABLE TO SEE BOTH --
PROFITABLE A ON NONPROFIT
CONTRIBUTIONS.
WHERE I'M NOT SURE WHY A NON
PROFIT -- CONTRIBUTION WOULD BE
CONTROVERSIAL -- AND IN FACT
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT EVERY US
PRESIDENT SINCE JIMMY CARTER.
EVERYONE OF THEM.
AND IN EVERY MAJOR PARTY.
CANDIDATE FOR US PRESIDENT SINCE
JIMMY CARTER HAVE RELEASED THEIR
TAX RETURNS IT'S GONE INTO THE
PUBLIC DOMAIN.
IN THE AMERICAN PUBLIC IN THE
PRESS AND HADN'T ABILITY TO BE
ABLE. TO REVIEW THE FITNESS OF
THAT PRESIDENT NOW.
THE CURRENT PRESIDENT IS NOW IN
THE WORLD'S LONGEST AUDIT FROM
THE IRS I GET IT.
I AIN'T -- EIGHT DISCLOSES VITAL
INFORMATION ON WHAT THE PUBLIC
NEEDS.
AND IT THAT ALSO INCLUDES
CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTIONS.
I I GUESS MY QUESTION WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU SAY THE REDACTED BY THE
FEDS WHO'S DOING THE REDACTING
AND AND WHAT'S THE FORCE OF LAW
FOR THAT WITH RELATION TO THIS
BILL. TO THE CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE IS A
AS STATED IN THE BILL WOULD
ACTUALLY DO THE REDACTING. FIVE
YEARS OF TAX.
RETURNS WOULD BE COLLECTED BY
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
THE SECTOR IS STATES OFFICE
WOULD ACTUALLY DO THE REDACTING
THIS INCIDENT PERMISSION SO FOR
EXAMPLE SOCIAL.
NUMBERS PERSONAL ADDRESSES HOME
PHONE NUMBERS -- BUT AGAIN I
WANT TO GO BACK TO THE PAST
FORTY YEARS.
THERE IS NOT BEEN A PRESIDENT.
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT.
WHO'S BEEN IN THE WHITE HOUSE
THAT HAS NOT RELEASED THEIR TAX
RETURNS IT HAS NOT HARM THEM.
HAS IT STARTED DEBATE IN THIS
NATION ABSOLUTELY BUT THAT
DEBATE IS HEALTHY FOCUSING ON
POTENTIAL CONFLICTS OF INTEREST
FOREIGN INVESTMENTS
RELATIONSHIPS WITH FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS.
BUSINESS INTERESTS I'M A AND THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC AND THE PRESS
DESERVED TO BE ABLE TO SEE THESE
IMPORTANT ITEMS.
CENTER GROVE THANK YOU MADAM AT
PRESIDENT I DO APPRECIATE THE
OTHER FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
HOWEVER I THINK IT IS A COMPLETE
AND ABSOLUTE VIOLATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION ARTICLE.
ONE AND YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT
THERE IS AN ISSUE WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND THERE HAS BEEN THIS
RESISTANCE MOVING FORWARD
CONTINUOUSLY.
BUT WE AS A BODY IN THIS STATE
NEED THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
THINGS AND IT WOULD BE NICE IF
WE COULD GET THE POLICY ISSUES
TO BE ABLE.
TO GARNER THE THINGS THAT WE
NEED FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IN A CONGENIAL WAY INSTEAD OF
JUST THE CONSTANT BARRAGE AN
ATTACK THIS IS A VIOLATION OF
OUR CONSTITUTION.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
INSTRUMENTAL IN YOU KNOW -- THE
FIRES THAT WE HAVE HERE IN THE
VALLEY THE DAMS THAT ARE BROKEN
WE DO HAVE OUR I NEED TO WORK
WITH OUR FEDERAL AT THE
ADMINISTRATION.
AND SO.
ASIDE FROM ALL OF THAT THE BILL
IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND VIOLATES
ARTICLE ONE OF THE CONSTITUTION
AND IT.
REQUIRES THINGS THAT ARE NOT
ACTUALLY APPROPRIATED SO I WOULD
JUST APPRECIATE A NO VOTE
[inaudible]
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
QUESTION THE AUTHOR.
WE ACCEPT THE QUESTION IT'S BEEN
A PRESENT THANK YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU HAVE HEARD A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR THE ME THAT
THEY DETERMINE THAT THE BILL IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL I WONDERED IF
YOU HAD -- LET'S COUNCIL OPINION
ON WHETHER OR NOT IT'S CONS THE
HAS BEEN IT'S THEIR OPINION
WHETHER OR NOT IT COULD BE
INTERPRETED AS CONSTITUTIONAL
ANNA THANK YOU SO MUCH. TO THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES
WE'VE HAD SEVERAL OPINIONS --
THAT HAVE WEIGHED IN ON THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THIS BILL.
THAT I COULD TALK ABOUT THREE
OKAY.
LEDGE COUNCIL LEDGE COUNCIL HAS
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE CAN'T
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THE BILL.
THE END THE CHIEF ETHICS
COUNCILS FOR BOTH GEORGE W. BUSH.
AS WELL AS BROCK OBAMA THEY HAVE
REVIEWED THE BILL.
AND THEY DECLARE THAT THEY
BELIEVE IT STANDS THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY TEST.
AND LOOK THE BOTTOM LINE IS IS
WE CAN ALL TALK WE CAN ALL
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THIS BILL.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO BE A LOOK TO
WHAT MAKES OUR DEMOCRACY STRONG.
THE FOUNDATION OF ANY SUCCESSFUL
GOVERNMENT IS TRANSPARENCY.
TRANSPARENCY.
IN ANDIDLY.
OVER THE LAST FORTY YEARS
PATRIOTS REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS OF LIKE IT'S STEPPED
UP TO BE ABLE TO RELEASE THEIR
TAX RETURNS THE RELEASE THEIR
TAX RETURNS BECAUSE IT'S A TIME
HONORED TRADITION.
IN OUR NATION'S DEMOCRACY.
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
REGARDLESS IF YOU'RE REPUBLICAN
REGARDLESS IF YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT.
THIS WILL HELP MAKE OUR
DEMOCRACY STRONGER -- A AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL ALSO BE
TESTED IN THE COURTS AND
RIGHTFULLY SO.
BUT TO BE ABLE TO ALSO TO
ADDRESS THE SENATORS -- QUESTION
ON BALLOT ACCESS REQUIREMENTS
WHICH IS ON THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY PORTION THAT
PEOPLE MAY BE CONCERNED ABOUT.
STATES HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO COLLECT SIGNATURE
GATHERING.
THEY HAD TO BE AT A SET
REQUIREMENTS IS THAT
REQUIREMENTS ON FILING FEES THE
MIDDLE DEADLINES ESSENTIALLY THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY IS FOCUS ON IF
EVERYONE CAN MEET THE DEMAND OF
THE STATE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE
CONSTITUTIONAL BECAUSE EVERYONE
WHO IS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT CAN
MEET THE DEMAND TO BE ABLE TO
RELEASE THEIR TAX RETURNS.
AND IT'S VERY CLEAR WITHIN THIS
BILL IF YOU DO NOT FILE TAX
RETURNS.
YOUR NAME WOULD ALSO SHOW ON THE
BALLOT.
SO THIS IS NOT PROHIBITED OF ANY
ONE INDIVIDUAL OR DIRECTED TO
ONE IN ANY ONE INDIVIDUAL AND
THAT IS WHAT THE COURTS ARE
GOING TO TAKE A LOOK AT ALL
RIGHT CENTER MCGUIRE CAN I
ACCEPT THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
SAY ONE LAST ITEM MEN AND
PRESIDENT -- IN THAT IS A TO THE
GOOD FOR IT SENATOR FROM FRESNO --
I GAVE HIM MY WORD THAT WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
POTENTIAL RELEASING OF TAX
RETURNS FOR CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS IN THE STATE -- I AM
NOT PREPARED TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
AN ANNOUNCEMENT ON THAT BUT WHAT
I WILL SAY IS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
FOCUSED ON THAT TRYING TO BE
ABLE TO MEET THE NEED OF THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM FRESNO.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO FOCUS
IN ON THAT AND HOPE THAT WE'LL
BE ABLE TO MAKE SOME HEADWAY
HERE IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS.
AND ALL THIS -- INDY HERE WITH
THIS.
THERE ARE VERY FEW TIMES.
WHERE YOU HAVE THE ETHICS
ATTORNEYS FOR BOTH GEORGE W.
BUSH?
AS WELL AS BARACK OBAMA AGREE.
AND THEY HAVE ALL AGREED THEY
BOTH AGREED.
THAT THIS WILL WITHSTAND THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY TAX.
IN SUPPORT OF TRANSPARENCY WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER SECRETARY THE ROLE
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
HI ATKINS.
I BATES.
NO BILL.
HI WE'RE JUST.
NO BRADFORD.
HI CAMBIADO HI I CHANGED
[inaudible]
NO DODD [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
THERE ALSO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER BY GROWTH [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BURKE.
HI HILL.
AYE HUESO AYE AYE -- TITLE AYE
JACKSON.
AYE JONES.
NO LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR HI MITCHELL
[inaudible]
HI MONEY.
HI MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
HI.
SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
BY STONE NO NO -- BURKE.
BY WHAT COUNTY.
BY WIENER.
BY WILK.
NO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ROTH.
PRICE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS TEN ON
THE URGENCY.
ICE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS TEN ON
THE BILL.
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
[inaudible]
SENATOR PORTANTINO.
YES MADAM PRESIDENT I'M PROUD TO
A KNOWLEDGE IN THE GALLERY
STUDENTS FROM GOODEN ELEMENTARY
FROM THE GREAT TWENTY FIFTH
SENATE DISTRICT AND THE
WONDERFUL COMMUNITY A SERRA
MADRE.
ARE HERE FOR THEIR CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND EDUCATION SO I
pWELCOME TO GOOD NO MATTER REYES.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE AND
LEARN A LOT.
WELCOME TO THE STUDENTS ARE GLAD
TO HAVE YOU HERE WITH US TODAY.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
THE SENATE THIRD READING WE'RE
ON ITEM NUMBER THIRTY TWO
SENATOR WIENER.
PASS ON FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
THREE SENATOR JACKSON.
FOUR SENATOR HILL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY BY
SENATOR HILL AND ACTUALLY TO
FARMS.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SB THREE TO
TWENTY WILL STRENGTHEN SECURITY
REQUIREMENTS OF FIRE ARM
RETAILERS TO HELP PREVENT FIRE
ARM THAT.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SEVENTEEN THIS HOUSE APPROVED US
BEFORE SIXTY FOR A BROADER
VERSION OF THIS POLICY.
THESE BILLS WERE THE WINNER OF
MY THERE OUGHT TO BE A LAW
CONTEST SUBMITTED BY
CONSTITUENT AFTER BURGLARS USED
A CAR. TO RAM INTO A GUN STORE
IN MY DISTRICT.
THE ROBBERS BROKE IN ON A SUNDAY
MORNING AND STORED IN STOLEN
UNDISCLOSED NUMBER OF GUNS LEFT
IN THEIR LASS DISPLAY CASES.
THIS WAS NOT AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT IN THESE TYPES OF
BURGLARIES ARE ON THE RISE THE A
TF TOLD MY OFFICE.
THAT AT LEAST ELEVEN OTHER
SIMILAR SMASH AND GRAB ROBBERIES
TOOK PLACE IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN IN THAT YEAR
INCLUDING ANOTHER IN MY DISTRICT
SIMILAR SMASH AND GRAB FIREARM
DEATHS HAVE OCCURRED MORE
RECENTLY IN LOOMIS FAIRFIELD
STOCKTON AND DIXON.
BETWEEN TWENTY THIRTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN GUN STORE
BURGLARIES INCREASED BY 71% IN
CALIFORNIA AND OVER THIRTEEN
HUNDRED GUNS WERE STOLEN. TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM IS BE TO
TWENTY UPDATES THE CURRENT
SECURITY STANDARDS FOR GUN
STORES IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN I
HOSTED A SERIES OF MEETINGS WITH
GUNS STORE OWNERS. TO SEE IF WE
CAN MAKE THE BILL MORE FLEXIBLE
AS A RESULT WE EXPANDED THE
NUMBER OF SECURITY OPTIONS FROM.
TWO TO SIX PROVIDING IMPROVE
COMPLIANCE OPPORTUNITIES WE ALSO
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION BY SIX
MONTHS TO GIVE TIME FOR STORAGE
TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE.
IT'S APPARENT FROM MY MEETINGS
AT MANY GUN STORES ARE ALREADY
IN COMPLIANCE WITH AT LEAST ONE
OF THESE REQUIREMENTS.
AND AS A RESULT I THINK THIS
BILL WILL IMPACT A SMALL NUMBER
OF STORES.
I THINK IT'S B. TWO TWENTY PUTS
FORWARD A REASONABLE AND
FLEXIBLE SOLUTION TO A REAL
PROBLEM I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE MEMBERS.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM [inaudible]
SAYING MAN.
SENATOR HALEY MAKES INCLUDE
REFRESH RIVAL COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU.
THANK MISTER SECRETARY THE ROLE
PLEASE.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NO BILL [inaudible]
HI FORGES.
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO HI I CHANGED
[inaudible]
NO DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER BY GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO BY OUR TITLE.
JACKSON BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL.
I MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
BY ROB [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE NO NUMBER.
HI MY COUNTY I WINNER BY WILK
[inaudible]
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GORGEOUS -- TACO [inaudible]
ROTH.
PLEASE CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS.
FOR JUST.
NO NO NO NO.
I TWENTY SIX KNOWS TEN MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE SENATOR GROW.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR GROWTH AND ACTUALLY TO
GRAND THEFT.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SO SB TWO TWENTY FOUR
MAKES AGRICULTURAL THEFT A PART
IN SEPARATE FROM GRAND THEFT.
THESE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE THROUGH -- THIS
AGRICULTURAL THEFT PROGRAM.
OUR ED CHAU RESULTS IN MAKING
SURE THAT NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES CAN WORK TOGETHER IN
SOLVING AGRICULTURE CRIMES.
THE MONEY THAT IS RECEIVED
FRIEND THESE PENALTIES AND
CRIMES WILL GO BACK TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND COASTAL ROLE
CRIMES PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
THE COUNTIES THAT PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PROGRAM ARE FRESNO KEEN
KERN KINGS MADERA MERCED MADE
MONTEREY SAN BENITO SANTA
BARBARA SANTA CRUZ AND SAN
JOAQUIN SAN LUIS OBISPO AND
STANISLAUS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF A RULE
COMMUNITY AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITIES THAT WOULD BENEFIT
FROM THIS. TO LARRY COUNTY ALONE
WE'RE NUMBER ONE AGRICULTURE
PRODUCING COUNTY IS SUSTAINED
OVER OF TWO MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF LOSSES.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW AND THE
PROCEEDS AND FINES COLLECTED TO
GO BACK SO FOR THESE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS CAN BETTER
ASSIST RULE CRIMES -- PREVENTION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
IT HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY NO VOTES.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SING NO COMMENTS BOB WE WE IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
AND UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM.
THERE IS AN OBJECTION BY MISTER
WHITE QUITE COSTLY.
AT SAID MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
AYE BILL.
I BRIDGES HI [inaudible] FOR BY
CARRIER HI I CHIANG.
I DOT [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI.
I GLAZER.
I GROWTH.
AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA.
I AM.
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL.
BY NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
HI ROSS.
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
BY STONE.
I AM BURKE.
BYE BYE CASKEY.
NO [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
HI WILK [inaudible]
HI.
ICE THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SIX CENTER
NIELSEN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE.
READ SENATE BILL TWO FORTY
NUMBER SENATOR NELSON AND
ACTUALLY TO LAND USE IN THE
CLING THERE'S THREATS TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
PRESENT LATEST DONE WITH THE
SENATE.
THIS BILL APPLIES ONLY TO BUTTE
COUNTY.
BUT IT WOULD BE A MODEL.
OF SOME HELP TO OTHER SIMILARLY
PLACE COUNTIES IN THE FUTURE OF
THAT BE OF INTEREST.
END OF I WAS SPEAKING ABOUT NOT
JUST THE CAR FIRE WERE NEARLY
NINETY PEOPLE.
LOST THEIR LIVES.
AND THOUSANDS OF HOMES.
THAT COUNTY ALSO.
AND BEEN INFLICTED BY OTHER
FIRES.
THAT WERE NOT QUITE AS
DEVASTATING.
BUT STILL PROBLEMATIC.
IN ADDITION TO AN EVACUATION.
OF ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
WHEN THEY SPILL WAY FAILURE
OCCURRED?
AT THE OROVILLE DAM SPILLWAYS.
AS THESE COMMUNITIES.
VERTICALLY PARADISE AND THE RICH
REBUILD.
THIS WOULD ALLOW.
THE BODIES THE LEGISLATIVE
BODIES IN THAT COUNTY THE EXTEND
THE LIFE OF THE SUBDIVISION MAPS
FOR THREE YEARS.
THAT IS HELPFUL TO GET.
THE REBUILDING PROCESS
[inaudible]
EXPEDITIOUSLY [inaudible]
ACCOMPLISHED. TO GET BACK TO
WORK. TO REPOPULATE. TO GET
PEOPLE BACK INTO THEIR HOMES.
IT WOULD EXTEND THE HEAD
EXPIRATION DATE.
OF ANY TENTATIVE SUBDIVISION MAP.
OR BESTING TENTATIVE MAP.
ON A PARTIAL.
LOWER PARTIAL MAP RATHER WHICH
RELIES ON THOSE MAPS.
IF THESE CONDITIONS OUR MATT.
IT'S RELATED TO A SINGLE OR
MULTI FAMILY.
HOUSING [inaudible]
A DWELLING.
APPROVED ON OR AFTER JANUARY
FIRST. TWO THOUSAND AND SIX AND
NOT LATER THAN MARCH THIRTY
FIRST [inaudible] TWENTY
NINETEEN AND IS NOT.
EXPIRED ON OR BEFORE.
THE EFFECTIVE DATE.
OF THIS BILL.
ITS EXPIRATION DATE WAS ALREADY
EXTENDED BY A. B. [inaudible]
THIRTEEN OH THREE IN
[inaudible] TWENTY FIFTEEN IT
ALSO EXTENDS THE APPROVAL WINDOW
TO ANY LEGISLATIVE
ADMINISTRATIVE OR STATE AGENCY
APPROVAL OF A DEVELOPMENT
PROJECT LOCATED.
IN THE MAP.
BY THREE YEARS.
THE POLICY COMMITTEE DID NOTE
AND GOOD TIMES IT'S EASY TO
COMPLY WITH THE MAPS CONDITION
IN A FEW YEARS.
THE PROBLEM OCCURS UNDER
DIFFICULT IN [inaudible]
URGENT [inaudible]
TIMES.
SUCH AS WE FACE WITH THESE FIRES
IN THIS BILL WAY FAILURE.
GETTING A FINAL APPROVAL.
AND SUCH UNDER SUCH ADVERSE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND TIMES CAN BE
PROBLEMATIC.
AND GREATLY DELAYED.
THIS BILL IS OF LIMITED SCOPE.
BOTH IN THE CRIME IS JUST WHAT
IT APPLIES.
TO THE MEANING THE COUNTY AND
THE CIRCUMSTANCES AS I JUST
RECITED THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES.
IT IS NECESSARY THIS TIMELY IT
IS LIMITED IN SCOPE.
IT HAS NOT BEEN HAD ANY
OPPOSITION.
AND I ENTREAT YOU TO VOTE ON BY.
AT HELP ALLOW THOSE CITIZENS. TO
GET THEIR LIVES BACK IN ORDER.
THANK YOU SENATOR IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ON THIS BILL.
SEEING NINE THIRTY EIGHT I KNOWS
ZERO ON THE URGENCY. THIRTY
EIGHT I KNOW ZERO ON THE BILL.
THE BILL PASSES.
MOVING ON ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
SEVEN SENATOR PAN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE.
READ SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY
FIVE A SENATOR PAN AND ACT
REALLY IN THE HEALING ARTS.
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT CENTERS I BRING YOU SB
TWO SEVENTY FIVE WHICH WOULD ADD
SEXUAL BEHAVIOR -- WHICH
INCLUDES INAPPROPRIATE ACTIONS
ARE COMMUNICATIONS OF A SEXUAL
NATURE PRECURSORS TO OUR AS
HARMFUL SEXUAL CONTACT WITH A
CLIENT OR FROM A CLIENT TO LIST
OF VIOLATIONS THAT WOULD REQUIRE
AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE'S.
RULING THE BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY
IS EXPERIENCE THE JUDICATA CASES
INVOLVING INAPPROPRIATE SEXUAL
CONDUCT THAT DID NOT MEET THE
CURRENT DEFINITION OF SEXUAL
CONDUCT AND THEREFORE DID NOT
REQUIRED THE LG TO RECOMMEND
REVOKING THE LICENSE.
SEXUAL BEHAVIOR TO
PSYCHOTHERAPISTS CLIENT
RELATIONSHIP BY LICENSE
PROFESSIONAL IS AN ETHICAL
VIOLATION AS IT VIOLATES THE
DUTY OF CARE AND HERE IN THE
THERAPEUTIC RELATIONSHIP ISSUES
THE TRUST OF THE CLIENT.
AND CREATE HARMFUL LONG LASTING
EMOTIONAL CYCLE LOGICAL FACTS WE
NEED TO OUR BOARD TO BE ABLE TO
ACT AND ADDRESS THESE PARTICULAR.
ISSUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I THOUGHT.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
MEMBERS ANY OBJECTION TO USING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM.
SAYING NINE FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR BELL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY FOUR BY
SENATOR BILL AN ACT RELATING TO
JUVENILES.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND YOUR BILL.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS -- THIS
BILL -- IS -- THE KEEP YOU'VE
CLOSE TO HOME ACT.
THE THE ANNUAL COST OF TO
CONFINE A YOUTH IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
AVERAGE IS OVER. THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER USE.
AND COUNTIES CONTRIBUTE -- WHEN
THEY SEND SOMEBODY -- TO THE
DEPARTMENT.
ONLY 8% OF THE COST OR TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS PER USE.
WITH THE STATE GOVERNMENT PAYING
FOR THE REST -- NOW WE SEE A
DRAMATIC DECLINE IN DEPARTMENT
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE POPULATION.
HOT HOT TEN THOUSAND IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX TO UNDER SEVEN
THOUSAND TODAY DO SO LARGE
SUPPLYING YOU CRIME ADDITION TO
REFORMS.
CARRY OUT BY THE LEGISLATURE.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT RAISES
THE COUNTY'S CONTRIBUTION TO A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS?
A YEAR FOR THE SUB SUB SET A
POPULATION -- THAT -- IN YEAR
ONE WE EXPECT THIS BILL TO
INCREASE THE STATE REVENUE BOOST
COST SAVINGS.
BY TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS --
WE DO NOT WANT TO A
UNNECESSARILY -- REFERRALS TO
OUR DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE.
IT'S MORE EFFECTIVE. TO SEND THE
YOUNG PEOPLE.
TO LOCAL PROBATION DEPARTMENT
FACILITIES RECENT DATA SHOW THAT
74% OF THE USE FROM DEPARTMENT
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE RESERVE
ENDED.
WITHIN THREE YEARS A RELEASE.
AND THE SAME SUPER PROMOTE
REHABILITATION CREATE SAY.
SUPPORTED AND SAFE ENVIRONMENTS
AND REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
KNOW [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
MISTER SECRETARY THERE -- PLEASE
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI.
ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
NOPE [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO HI HI JANE
[inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI.
HILL.
BY WITH A HIGHER TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES NO.
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
I BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
BY STONE.
NO NUMBER.
BY WORK OWSKI HI HI WIENER BY
[inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
GROVE NO [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY.
ICE THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
NINE ON ON OUR AGENDA
[inaudible]
SENATOR RUBIO.
PASS ON FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
SENATOR WILK.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FOUR NINE BY SENATOR
WILL AN ACT RELATING TO ILLEGAL
DUMPING.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB FORO NINE
HELPS LAW ENFORCEMENT IN STATE
AND LOCAL AGENCIES STOP PROPERTY
OWNERS IN TRUCK CALLERS FROM
ENGAGING IN UNLAWFUL DUMPING THE
RESULT IN ENVIRONMENTAL
POLLUTION.
AND DAMAGE TO OUR PUBLIC
ROADWAYS EXISTING LAW DRESSES
ONLY SITUATIONS WHEN THE
PROPERTY OWNERS DO NOT GIVE
PERMISSION TO UNLAWFULLY DUMP
WASTE MATTER ON THEIR PROPERTY.
HOWEVER MANY PROPERTY OWNERS ARE
GIVING TRUCK CALLER'S PERMISSION
DUMP WASTE MATTER ON THEIR LAND
WITHOUT FIRST OBTAINING THE
REQUIRED PERMITS FROM STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES.
PROPERTY OWNERS PROFIT FROM
COLLECTING CASH WHAT TRUCK CALL
CALLER OPERATORS PROFIT FROM
CHARGING THE HIGH COST FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION AWAY WAYS
INTENDED FOR A LICENSE DUMPSITE.
INSTEAD DELIVERY THE WAYS TO
PROPERTY OWNERS LAND FOR FAR
LOWER AMOUNT OF MONEY THERE BY
POCKETING THE DIFFERENCE.
SB FOUR NINE CLOSES LOOPHOLES
STATE LAW BY DRESSING SITUATIONS
WHICH A PROPERTY OWNER GETS
CONSENT ENHANCE TRANSPORTERS A
WASTE TO THE STATUTE.
THE BILL'S CO SPONSORED BY THE
LA DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT BY THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM.
SEEING NINE THIRTY EIGHT I ZERO
NO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FORTY
ONE SENATOR RUBIO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT RELATING TO
THE SAN GABRIEL WATER QUALITY
AUTHORITY.
WARRIORS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING AS BEFORE ONE THREE
EIGHT DISTRICTS SPECIFIC BILL
THAT WOULD MODIFY THE ELECTION.
FOR THE SAN GABRIEL BASIN WATER
QUALITY AUTHORITY AND
CONSOLIDATE DUPLICATIVE REPORTS
BY CUTTING DOWN ON THE NUMBER
SPECIAL ACTIONS AND REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF REPORTS THAT MUST BE
PREPARED.
THIS BILL SAVES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TAX TIME AND
TAXPAYER MONEY.
SB FOUR ONE THREE IS SPONSORED
BY THE SAN GABRIEL BASIN WATER
QUALITY AUTHORITY AND HOUSE NO
OPPOSITION AND PASSED UT OF
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE.
AND SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE WITH UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH WITH
THAT I ASKED FOR YOUR RIVAL. FOR
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ON THIS ITEM.
SEE NO OBJECTION.
ICE.
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY TWO SENATOR PENN.
PASS ON FILE.
ITEM FORTY THREE CENTER MCGUIRE
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 4409% REQUIRE AN ACT
GOING TO PASS CONTROL MAKING
PREPARATION THEREFORE. FOR IS
YOURS HEY THANK YOU SO MUCH
BETTER PRESIDENT THE GOLDEN
STATE MAKES 81%. 81% OF ALL ONE
IN AMERICA AND WE HAVE THE
FOURTH.
LEADING WINE PRODUCER SB FOUR
FOUR NINE EXTENDS THE EXISTING
PIERCE'S DISEASE CONTROL PROGRAM
TO TWENTY TWENTY SIX AND
CONTINUES IMPORTANT RESEARCH
EFFORTS TO COMBAT THIS
DEVASTATING DISEASE IN CODIFIES
FUNDING FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
MEMBERS I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SENATOR JIM NIELSEN.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADY CHEN ON THE
SENATE I RISE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GRAPE AND WINE INDUSTRY IS VERY
INTEGRAL AND HISTORIC IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS THIS STATE GREW. HUNDRED
YEARS AGO [inaudible]
WITH THE COMING OF THE FATHER
SIERRA'S.
SERRA'S AND OTHERS.
ON THE CHURCH GROUNDS
[inaudible]
THEY BEGAN [inaudible]
WINE CULTIVATION.
AND THAT BECAME.
A TREMENDOUS CROP IN THE STATE.
A CROP THAT PUT CALIFORNIA ON
THE WORLD MAP.
OUR CALIFORNIA WINES LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN.
ARE RANKED IN THE HIGHEST AND
BEST.
IN THE WORLD. ONE OF THE
WINERIES THAT I DID REPRESENT.
SENATOR DODD NOW REPRESENTS. ONE
A BLIND TASTING IN PARIS.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR THAT
STUNNED THE WORLD.
WHAT PIERCE'S DISEASE WOULD DO
IS GREAT A HAZARD THE FUTURE OF
THIS INDUSTRY?
AND OUR OPPORTUNITY TO FIGHT
THIS DREAD DISEASE.
AND ALWAYS WE FACE IN CALIFORNIA
INVASIVE SPECIES AND DISEASE
THIS IS A CRITICAL NEED I WOULD
ASK THAT WE CONTINUE THE PROGRAM
AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THUNDERSTONE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT ELECT I THINK THE
SENDER FROM HILLS UBER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AS A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN THE
CITY TO MACULA LATER COUNTY
SUPERVISOR 20% OF OUR WINE
COUNTRY WHICH DECIMATED BY THE
GLASSY WINGED SHARPSHOOTER WE
SECURED THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDING.
VERY PROUD THE UC ARE A CAME UP
WITH THE ANTIDOTE -- FOR
PIERCE'S DISEASE WE SAVED OUR
WINE COUNTRY AND INTO MACULA
WHICH NOW IS HOME TO OVER SIXTY
WINERIES.
AND I MIGHT ADD IS THE ONLY ONE
COUNTRY TO HAVE A WINERY SOUTH
COAST WINERY THAT HAS WON THE
GOLDEN BEAR AWARD. FOUR TIMES SO
PLEASE -- BUT YES ON AS BEFORE
FOUR NINE THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE [inaudible]
SEEING NONE [inaudible]
CENTER JONES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS GREAT
BILL A COUPLE OF FACTS ABOUT SAN
DIEGO COUNTY THAT TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW IS CURRENTLY
THERE'S OVER ONE HUNDRED
WINERIES.
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND PRIOR TO
PROHIBITION SAN DIEGO COUNTY WAS
THE NUMBER ONE WINE PRODUCING
AREA IN CALIFORNIA.
SO I ALSO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SINGMAN CENTER MCGUIRE YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
SENATORS FROM TO HAMMER TO
MACULA INTO SANTEE. FOR THEIR
GOOD WORDS HERE TODAY WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE SENATOR
FROM NAPA FOR OFFICE WORK ON
THIS LEGISLATION AS WELL WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM.
THING NO OBJECTIONS THIRTY EIGHT
EYES.
NOSE.
ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA RETURN TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
AND RECOGNIZED SENATOR RURAL
MAYBE I GUESS WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO THE PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR.
I WAS JUST A TRICK YOU SEE IF
YOUR WAKE WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER [inaudible]
FORTY FOUR SENATOR STERN.
PASS ON FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
FIVE CENTRE RIGHT HUSKY.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR Y. CASKEY AN ACT
RELATING TO DEBT COLLECTION.
FLOOR IS YOURS MADAM PRESIDENT
THIS MEASURE -- CLARIFIES THAT
THE TERM CONSUMER DEBT UNDER THE
ROSENTHAL FAIR DEBT -- ERR FEAR
DEBT COLLECTION PRACTICE
INCLUDES MORTGAGE DEBT I REGION
I VOTE.
IS THERE ANY FOR A DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE.
THIS.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING. NINE THIRTY EIGHT I ZERO
KNOWS THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FORTY SIX SENATOR
MCGUIRE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL FOR THIRTY ONE
BY SENATOR REQUIRE AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS. FOR YEARS
THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER PRESENT
THE GOLDEN STATE ORDER REQUIRES
EVERY HIGH SCHOOL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SEE SOON YOU SEE THAT
REQUEST VOTER REGISTRATION FORM
TO BE SENT TO THOSE.
SCHOOLS FREE OF CHARGE BUT THERE
IS A CHALLENGE THERE'S NO TIME
FRAME FOR THOSE VOTER
REGISTRATION FORMS TO BE
DELIVERED SB FOUR THIRTY ONE
GUARANTEES THERE'S PROACTIVE
PROCESS FOR ALL HIGH SCHOOL
COLLEGE STUDENTS. TO ACQUIRE
VOTER REGISTRATION FORMS BY
REQUIRING THEM. TO BE SENT
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF THE
REQUEST BY SCHOOL WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I BUILT.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
SEEING MAN [inaudible]
BUT MISTER SECRETARY THE WROCLAW
PLEASE [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES.
BILL.
I POOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO HI I CHANGE.
HI DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO.
AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HI HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON.
I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
I'M REQUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
THE REALM [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
IOWA CASKEY.
I WINNER.
HI WILK [inaudible]
HI HI.
PLEASE CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS
BATES [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI. FIVE THIRTY THREE NO THREE
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
FORTY SEVEN CENTER WIENER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
READ.
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY THREE
PRESS SENATOR WINNER AND ACT
RELATED CRIMES.
FLOOR IS YOURS MISTER WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT.
OUR COLLEAGUES -- SP TWO THIRTY
THREE IS A VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD --
PIECE OF LEGISLATION FIVE TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
SEX WORKERS.
RAY NAILS SEX WORKERS ARE AT
EXTREME RISK OF BEING VICTIMIZED
BY VIOLENCE OF BEING KIDNAPPED
RAPED ASSAULTED MURDERED -- WE
NOTE THE STATISTICS ARE OFF THE
CHARTS THAT SEX WORKERS ARE ON
BADLY BADLY VICTIMIZE -- IN
ADDITION -- SEX WORKERS ARE AT
SIGNIFICANT RISK OF HIV AND
OTHER SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
INFECTIONS.
SO WE ONE SEX WORKERS TO BE IN A
POSITION TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
AND UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT NOW --
THEY ARE NOT BECAUSE OF FEAR OF
ARREST.
AND SO SB TWO THIRTY THREE DOES
A TWO THINGS FIRST IT PROVIDES
THAT IF A SEX WORKER HAS BEEN --
VICTIMIZED -- BY SERIOUS AND
VIOLENT CRIMES SUCH AS RAPE OR
KIDNAPPING ETCETERA.
AND IF THAT SEX WORKER THEN
REPORTS THE CRIME -- THAT PERSON
CAN NOT BE ARRESTED FOR SEX WORK
OR SEX WORK RELATED -- OFFENSES --
WE KNOW THAT A FIVE SEX WORKER
BELIEVES THAT HE OR SHE WILL BE
ARRESTED IF THEY GO AND REPORT
CRIME TO THE POLICE.
MAN THAT SUCKS WERE WILL NOT
COME FORWARD AND NOT ONLY WHAT
THE SEX WORKER -- BE AT RISK BUT
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY WILL BE
LESS SAFE BECAUSE SOMEONE WHO IS
COMMITTING VIOLENT CRIMES WILL
NOT BE ARRESTED AND TAKEN OFF
THE STREETS.
HI IN ADDITION -- THE BILL --
ROD PREVENTS -- THE USE OF
CONDOMS AS EVIDENCE OF SEX WORK
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE PARTS OF THE
STATE -- WHERE A SEX WORKER WILL
BE ARRESTED AND THE FACT THAT
THAT SEX WORKER HAS THREE OR
FOUR CONDOMS IN THEIR POSSESSION
THAT WILL BE USED AS A BASIS OF
PROBABLE CAUSE?
AND IT CAN BE USED IN COURT AS
EVIDENCE OF SEX WORK -- THIS
BILL WILL PUT A STOP TO THAT WE
WANT TO CREATE INCENTIVES FOR
SEX WORKERS TO PROTECT THEIR
SEXUAL HEALTH.
AND USE CONDOMS AND THE LAST
THING THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING IS
SENDING A SIGNAL THAT IF YOU
CARRY CONDOMS WITH YOU THAT IS
GOING TO MAKE IT MORE LIKELY
THAT YOU GOT ARRESTED.
AND PROSECUTED SO THIS BILL WILL
ENCOURAGE SEX WORKERS TO COME
FORWARD AND REPORT VIOLENT
CRIMES AND WILL ENCOURAGE THEM
TO CARRY CONDOMS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
YOU MAY CALL THE YOU MAY CLOSE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THIS ITEM AT REQUIRES TWENTY
SEVEN VOTES.
PLEASE READ THE ROLE
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL.
THE BILL.
HI [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BEDFORD.
HI CARRIER HI I CHANGED
[inaudible]
NO DODD [inaudible]
HI DORADO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GROWTH.
NO.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON.
BY JONES.
NO.
LEYVA.
I'M ACQUIRED BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
HI MONEY.
HI MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN.
HI PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN BY STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
HI MY COUNTY I WIENER.
AYE WILK [inaudible]
NO.
ICE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS.
TEN THE ITEMS PASS THIS.
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
CENTER PAN.
PASS ON FILE FORTY NINE SENATOR
LEYVA.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY SEVEN BY SENATOR LEYVA
RELATIVE TO FIVE TWENTY NINE
COLLEGE SAVINGS DAY.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS I RISE TODAY AS
A PROUD AUTHOR OF S. C. R.
THIRTY SEVEN WHICH PROCLAIMS THE
MAY TWENTY NINTH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS FIVE
TWENTY NINE COLLEGE SAVINGS DAY
A FIVE TWENTY NINE COLLEGE
SAVINGS PLAN IS A PLAN THAT
PROVIDES FAMILIES WITH A
VALUABLE INVESTMENT TOOL.
MORE THAN A DOZEN STATES
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA OFFER
MATCHING CONTRIBUTIONS TO FIVE
TWENTY NINE COLLEGE SAVINGS
PLANS TO ENCOURAGE LOW AND
MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES TO SAVE
NOW FOR FUTURE SCHOOLING.
IN CALIFORNIA THE SCHOLARSHIP
INVESTMENT BOARD CHAIR BY STATE
TREASURER FIONA MALL IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ADMINISTERING
THESE PLANS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE ANY OBJECTION TO THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
THING NINE FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY SENATOR BELL.
PASS ON FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
ONE CENTER STERN.
PASS ON FILE NUMBER FIFTY TWO
SENATOR WILK.
PASS ON FILE NUMBER FIFTY THREE
SENATOR GLACIER.
PASS ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
FIFTY FOUR SENATOR HILL
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY THREE
BY THE COMMITTEE ON LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT.
AN ACT RELATING TO RETIREMENT.
CENTER HELLO THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- SB
SEVEN EIGHTY THREE IS THE SENATE
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE BILL FOR
THE THIRTY SEVEN ACT COUNTY
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS THIS BILL IS
A TECHNICAL HOUSEKEEPING BILL
THAT SIMPLY CORRECT OBSOLETE OR
HEIRONEOUS REFERENCES IN THE
GOVERNMENT CODE.
RELATED TO COUNTY RETIREMENT
SYSTEMS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE MEMBERS THANKS VERY
MUCH IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE -- ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NONE EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR HILL ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
FIVE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY FIVE
A SENATOR HILL AN ACT RELATING
TO PARTY BUSES. FOR YEARS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I
HOPE A LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT LAW
MAKES T ILLEGAL FOR PASSENGERS
TO SMOKE CANNABIS IN A PARTY BUS
LIMO TAXI OR TNC.
AS A RESULT SOME PARTY BUSES AND
LIMO OPERATORS ARE OFFERING
CANNABIS DISPENSARY TOURS
SIMILAR TO EXISTING TOWARDS TO
WINERIES OR BREWERIES
SPECIFICALLY SB SIX TWENTY FIVE
MAKES IT ILLEGAL FOR A PASSENGER
IN A PARTY.
BUS OR LIMO TO TO SMOKE OR VAPOR
CANNABIS UNLESS THE DRIVER'S
COMPARTMENT IS SEALED OFF AND
SEPARATELY VENTILATED.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THE
DRIVER IS NOT IMPAIRED IF
CANNABIS SMOKERS CONSUMED IN ONE
OF THESE FOR HIGHER VEHICLES.
AS THE BILL MOVED TO THE
ASSEMBLY I WILL BE WORKING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
DEVELOP CLEAR STANDARDS. FOR
ENSURING THAT A PARTY BUS HAS
ADEQUATE SAFETY MECHANISMS IN
PLACE.
THIS BILL WILL ESTABLISH SAFETY
RULES TO PROTECT CONSUMERS AND
ELIMINATE BAD ACTORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
MEMBERS.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
THING THEN.
ANY OBJECTION TO A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM.
SAYING MAN I THE I CAN SEE
EVERYBODY'S DESTRUCTION I'M NOT
SURE WHY THIRTY EIGHT ICE.
KNOWS ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS -- WE'RE GONNA GO BACK.
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
[inaudible]
SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU -- MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS -- ALL PRINCES LAY IS
ALSO HERE AND WE'VE BEEN JOINED.
BY THE FORCE WERE WELL PROTECTED
TODAY YOU COULD SEE THEM UP IN
THE GALLERY I'D LIKE.
THAT'S RACIST.
THERE WE GO THANK YOU SENATORS
STERN FOR THAT MUSICAL INTERLUDE.
SO -- WE ARE.
WE ARE WE ARE QUITE QUITE.
PRIVILEGE TODAY TO RECOGNIZE.
AN IMPORTANT AN IMPORTANT EVENT
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY FORTY TWO
YEARS AGO THE STAR WARS
FRANCHISE TOOK US TO THE GALAXY
FAR FAR AWAY IN CAPTURED OUR
IMAGINATIONS WITH THE CLASSIC
TALE.
OF GOOD VERSUS EVIL THE STAR
WARS FRANCHISE MADE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CALIFORNIA'S
MOTION PICTURE INDUSTRY AND
CONTINUES TO BE A CULTURAL
CENTER PLEASE.
WELL THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
ALL AROUND THE WORLD -- NOW THE
OPENING OF STAR WARS GALAXIES
EDGE IS THE LARGEST SINGLE SITE
EXPANSION TO DATE.
AT DISNEYLAND PARK WHICH HAPPENS
TO BE IN THE THIRTY FOUR SENATE
DISTRICT THE MOST IMPORTANT
SENATE DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA --
IT REPRESENTS IT INVESTMENT OVER
ONE BILLION DOLLARS -- THIS
INVESTMENT TRANSLATES IN THE
CREATION OF OVER ONE THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED PERMANENT JOBS.
IN AT LEAST FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL TAX REVENUE --
THE FORCE IS STRONG IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE RECOGNIZE MAY
FOURTH.
OF THIS YEAR IS STAR WARS DAY
IT'S MY PLEASURE REDUCE --
SEVERAL OF THE IMPORTANT
CHARACTERS IN ADDITION TO THE
STORM TROOPERS FROM DISNEY AND
DISNEYLAND UP FIRST JOSH
TOMORROW PRESIDENT DISNEYLAND
RESORT IS HERE WITH US -- MISS
LISA HAYNES.
LISA HAYNES THE VICE PRESIDENT
COMMUNICATIONS AND PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CARRYING A CELLO.
AS WELL AS LISA PITNEY.
SO IF YOU WOULD ALL JOIN ME AND
AND RECOGNIZING -- THE
ACHIEVEMENT AND ALSO THE
CULTURAL ICON THAT THAT STAR
WARS AND DISEASE BECOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
.
A SENATE WELCOME TO THE
PARATROOPERS THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY.
I AM.
YES SENATOR UMBERG.
YES THE YOUR INDULGENCE IN THE
ADULT IS OF THE MEMBERS THERE
THERE'S BEEN A REQUEST FROM
SEVERAL MEMBERS -- TO HAVE THEIR
PICTURE TAKEN WITH THE STORM
TROOPERS SO I WOULD ASK IF THEY
WOULD.
COME DOWNSTAIRS IN THE IN THE
VERY BACK OF THE CHAMBER OF
OUTSIDE THE DOORS SO THAT.
PRINCES LAY AND OTHERS CAN
OUTSIDE THE DOORS CAN HAVE THEIR
PHOTO TAKEN WITH THEM SO SO IT'S
YOUR AS OLD AS YOU CAN TELL I'VE
I'VE LOST TOTAL CONTROL OVER THE
FLOOR IT'S JUST TO HAVE IT YES.
WELL THAT WILL TAKE A COUPLE OF
MINUTES TO BE ABLE TO USE.
THE FORCE WITH YOU I CAN TELL
YES I WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DO THE SIGNAL SO THAT
THEY THEY ANDERSON.
LET'S JUST TAKE A MINUTE SO WE
CAN FINISH UP A COUPLE THINGS ON
THE FILE OKAY.
THANK YOU CAN.
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE FILE.
AND THEN WE'LL TAKE WE'LL TAKE.
WHAT LET LET'S DO THIS WHY DON'T
WE -- FINISH THE THERE WERE A
COUPLE OF ITEMS THAT WE WANTED
TO GET THROUGH AND THEN WILL.
WE WE CAN ADJOURN INTAKE PICTURE
[inaudible]
SO MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO WORK -- ONE MORE
BILL ON THE FILE.
SO OBVIOUSLY VERY EXCITING TO
HAVE VISITORS TODAY BUT WE'VE
GOT ONE MORE ITEM TO TAKE UP ON
THE THIRD SENATE THIRD READING
WHICH IS ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTY SIX SENATOR ALLEN PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR ALLEN AN ACT RELATING
TO PEOPLE ASSESSMENT.
IS YOUR CENTER THE MINUTE
PRESENT MEMBERS -- THIS IS A
BILL THAT REPEALED AN OBSOLETE
EDUCATION CODE SECTION REALLY TO
KEEP PEOPLE ASSESSMENTS THAT IS
NO LONGER OPERATIVE I RESPECT
RESTAURANT VOTE.
IS IT IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
SITTING.
NINE ANY OBJECTION TO THE USING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM.
THING NINE FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES THAT
CONCLUDES OUR SENATE THIRD
READING.
WE HAVE OUR CONSENT AGENDA ITEMS
ITEMS NUMBER NINETY SEVEN
THROUGH.
ONE OH FOUR IS THERE ANY MEMBER
THAT WOULD LIKE AN ITEM REMOVED
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY SIX SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION SIX SENATE BILL
324-635-08780 NINE AND SENATE
BILL.
TWO FIFTY SEVEN YES BEFORE YOU
GO ON THE JUST -- RECENTLY
RESPECTFULLY THE GERMS AND YOU
CAN GO OKAY.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
TO THE THE CONSENT. THIRTY EIGHT
FIVE ZERO NO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
THE NEXT ITEM IS COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
ANNOUNCEMENTS [inaudible]
SENATOR DODD.
WE'LL GET TO HAVE THE CAUCUS
MEETING FOR THE JUST WENT.
BRAIN DEAD.
THE DELTA CAUCUS MEETING WILL BE
HELD AT FOUR THIRTY SEVEN RIGHT
AFTER -- SENATE MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM PRESIDENT LET ME JUST SAY
TO ALL THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
PATIENTS HUMANS HAVE MY YOUNG
PADAWAN.
WE ARE HAVING BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE MEETINGS TODAY AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT WE HAVE FULL
COMPLETE ATTENDANCE BECAUSE IN
SUB SUB COMMITTEE -- SOME SUB
COMMITTEES WILL ACTUALLY BE
TAKING VOTES TODAY.
SO YOU'RE ABOUT TO HEAR THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OF ALL THE
SUBCOMMITTEES BUT AS BUDGET HERE
I WANTED TO JUST ANNOUNCED THAT
WERE BEGINNING TO MOVE INTO THE
THINGS THAT TAKING VOTES WE GOT
WE HAVE FULL.
ATTENDANCE FOR THE DURATION OF
THE COMMITTEE HEARINGS THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANNOUNCEMENT
SENATOR MITCHELL
SENATOR PAN.
Q. MADAM PRESIDENT -- THIS AN
OUNCE THAT -- SENATE BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WILL BE RE MEETING IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE AT
ELEVEN TWENTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR DR SO.
I YES THANK YOU -- MADAM CHAIR
SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOUR WILL BE
MEETING IN FIVE MINUTES.
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY THANK YOU.
SENATOR ROTH.
THINK ABOUT A PRESIDENT BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
EDUCATION WILL BE MEETING AT
ELEVEN FIFTEEN IN ROOM.
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE ENTER
RIGHT KASKI SUBCOMMITTEE TO ON
RESOURCES FIREMAN PROTECTION
ENERGY AND TRANSPORTATION WILL
MEET TEN MINUTES UPON THE GERMAN
IN ROOM [inaudible]
ONE ONE TWO SENATOR SKINNER.
FIVE ON PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE
JUDICIARY WILL MEET FIVE MINUTES
AFTER ADJOURNMENTS.
IN ROOM [inaudible]
ONE THIRTEEN VERY GOOD.
I THAT CONCLUDES THE
ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR TODAY
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THIS IS THE TIME FOR THE
INTERNET MEMORY SO IF EVERYBODY
COULD TAKE THEIR SEATS.
WE CAN UP PROCEED WITH THE
ATTORNEY MEMORIES [inaudible]
SENATOR JACKSON.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO ASK
YOU.
TO ADJOURN WITH ME IN MEMORY OF
JEAN KELLOGG SKYLER.
SANTA BARBARA LOST A STAUNCH
SUPPORTER OF THE ARTS THE
ENVIRONMENT THE COMMUNITY
EDUCATION.
AND WOMEN'S ISSUES WITH HER
DEATH ON APRIL SEVENTEENTH.
JEAN GREW UP IN ALTADENA HORIA
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
FAMILIAR WITH THE LOCAL AREA.
HER FATHER WAS W. S. KELLOGG.
OF KNOWN.
FOR HIS WORK WITH THE SCRIPTS
CLINIC AND SCRIPTS MEMORIAL
HOSPITAL AS WELL AS HIS
OWNERSHIP OF THE LOCAL AREA.
BEACH CLUB.
HE AYE TORCHING THE VALUE OF
GIVING BACK AND THIS WAS A WOMAN
WHO WAS EXTRAORDINARY IN HER
GENEROSITY HER PHILANTHROPY.
BUT WAS AS QUIET A VOICE.
AS POSSIBLE IN FACT AS I WAS
TRYING TO GET MORE INFORMATION
I'D I'VE KNOWN GENE OR NEW CHAIN
FOR ABOUT FORTY YEARS.
IT WAS SO HARD TO GET THAT
INFORMATION BECAUSE SHE WAS
SOMEONE WHO TRULY BELIEVED THAT
IT WAS THE WORK THAT MATTERED.
NOT HER NOT HER PERSONALITY IT
WAS THE WORK AND HER ABILITY TO
HELP SUPPORT THESE.
EXTENDED PHILANTHROPIES FROM
STRONG COMMITMENT TO THE
ENVIRONMENT AND CONSERVATION SHE
WAS A LIFELONG -- WILDERNESS
LOVER -- HER FAMILY WAS VERY
CLOSE TO THE JOHN YOUR FAMILY.
AND SPENT FIFTY YEARS ENJOYING
AND PROTECTING THE GORGEOUS
WILDERNESS OF OUR GREAT STATE
[inaudible]
SHE WAS BOTH THE CHAIR OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SOLUTIONS SHE AND HER
HUSBAND BERRY WHO WAS A
PROFESSOR UC SANTA BARBARA SOME
FAR MENTAL STUDIES FOR YEARS --
ADVOCATED AND AND SUPPORTED AND
HELPED TO CREATE AND PROTECT THE
DOUGLAS FAMILY PRESERVE THE L.
WOULD MASON THE BUTTERFLIES.
THE CITRIC RESERVE AMONG SO MANY
EFFORTS TO REALLY KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY BEAUTIFUL AND TO MAKE
IT AVAILABLE FOR EVERYONE TO
ENJOY.
NATURE IN ITS PRISTINE SIMPLEST
MOST MAGNIFICENCE THAT WAS JEAN
SKYLER.
SO I IN TURN IN HER MEMORY --
JEAN HAD A STROKE BACK ABOUT TEN
YEARS AGO LEFT HER PARTIALLY
PARALYZED IN.
SHOULD DIFFICULTY SPEAKING BUT
JEAN WAS AT EVERY EVENT UP UNTIL
JUST A FEW SHORT WEEKS AGO.
HAD TROUBLE TALKING BUT WASN'T
THERE TO TALK WAS THERE TO
EXTEND HER SUPPORT HER
CONFIDENCE IN THE EFFORTS THAT
PEOPLEARE MAKING TO KEEP AND
MAKE OUR COMMUNITY BETTER.
SHE WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY WOMAN
AND SO DIVERSE IN HER INTERESTS
AND HER PASSION FOR PHILANTHROPY.
SO THE COMMUNITY OF SANTA
BARBARA HAS LOST ONE OF ITS
FINEST IN HOMELESS STEWARDS.
BUT WHILE SHE'S NO LONGER WITH
US HER AND DURING SPIRIT FOR
GIVING BACK.
IS ALIVE THROUGHOUT OUR
COMMUNITY.
HAS CONTINUED AND WILL CONTINUE
TO INSPIRE US.
AND WILL SERVE AS THE EXAMPLE OF
TRUE.
WARMTH TRUE GENEROSITY TRUE
COMMUNITY SPIRIT THAT IS WHAT
HAS MADE THIS STATE SO GREAT I
WOULD ASK YOU TO IS A JOIN ME IN
A TURNING IN HER MEMORY AND
SENDING OUR CONDOLENCES TO HER
FAMILY.
PLEASE BRING YOUR NAME TO THE
DEATH SO THAT HER MEMORY CAN BE
MEMORIALIZED [inaudible]
SENATOR PENN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS -- TODAY I RISE --
ALONG WITH MY GOOD FRIEND --
FROM MY NAPA -- TO TURN IN
MEMORY OF BILL GRAHAM.
WHO IS A SENIOR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FOR THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR USE LAWS WAS A FRIEND WHO I
WORKED WITH FIGHTING FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AND IMPROVED
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES FOR
ALL?
OVER THE YEARS BILL HAS HAD MANY
ADVERSITY VICTORIES IMPROVING
THE LIVES OF THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN IN UTAH WASHINGTON
ARKANSAS NEVADA AND OF COURSE.
CALIFORNIA AND BEYOND CREATING
CRITICAL PROTECTIONS FOR
CHILDREN ENSURING CHILDREN
RECEIVE THE OPPORTUNITIES AND
SUPPORTS TO WHICH THEY WERE
ENTITLED.
USE THE VOTED IN A SERVICE TO
VULNERABLE CHILDREN HE INSPIRED
AND MENTORED GENERATION OF CHILD
ADVOCATES.
HE WILL ALWAYS BE WITH US AS WE
WORK TIRELESSLY TO ADVANCE
JUSTICE ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN WITH TO WHOM HE
COMMITTED HIS LIFE.
BELIEVE -- IN THE GALLERY -- WE
WILL ARE JOINED BY BILL'S WIFE
SHERRY AND PLEASE JOIN ME.
IN A JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY OF
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
SENATOR DODD.
PLEASE EXTEND THE SENATE'S
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY OF
BILL GRAHAM FOR FOR US PLEASE
[inaudible]
SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
SIDE TO A JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY
OF ELISABETH JINX AKKI.
WHO PASSED AWAY ON MARCH TWENTY
THIRD TWENTY NINETEEN SHE WAS
BORN IN INDIANA JULY THIRTIETH
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE AND SPENT
MOST OF HER CHILDHOOD MOVING ALL
OVER INDIANA?
WHILE HER PARENTS LOOK FOR WORK
DURING THE GREAT DEPRESSION.
SHE MOVED WEST WITH THEIR
FAMILIES ARE JUST IN SEARCH OF A
BETTER LIFE BETTER WEATHER AND
SETTLED IN SAN DIEGO.
SHE ATTENDED SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY GRADUATING WITH A
DEGREE IN SPEECH PATHOLOGY IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE DURING
COLLEGE SHE WAS INTRODUCED TO
HER SOON TO BE HUSBAND CALL A
KEY OF THE EKIE POINSETTIA.
RANTS FAMILY OF ANTHONY DOES.
IN MADE HER MARK ALONGSIDE HIM.
AND HER IN LAWS GROWING THE
POINSETTIA REACTION TO A
WORLDWIDE BUSINESS THE LARGEST
OF ITS KIND.
IN POINSETTIA PLANTS WHILE ALSO
RAISING THREE CHILDREN.
SHE DEDICATED MUCH OF HER TIME
TO SERVING HER COMMUNITY IN
NORTHERN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
SERVING AS PRESIDENT.
OF THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL.
SANDY SANDY GUIDO UNITS AND
SERVED ON THE CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALITY CHARITY BALL
COMMITTEE SHE HAD A LIFELONG
INTEREST IN PROMOTING EQUAL
RIGHTS FOR WOMEN.
AND FOUNDED THE ISABELLA FUND
TOWARDS THE SAND.
HER KINDNESS GENEROSITY AND
DEDICATION TO HER COMMUNITY IS
AN EXAMPLE FOR US ALL.
SURVIVED BY HER THREE CHILDREN
NINE GRAND CHILDREN AND HER
BROTHERS AND SISTERS A
CELEBRATION OF HER LIFE.
WILL BE HELD ON MAY TWENTY SIX
AT THE FLOWER FIELDS IN CARLSBAD.
I ASK THAT WE A JOURNEY AND
ELISABETH AND KEYS MEMORY.
SEND CONDOLENCES TO HER FAMILY
ON THE LOSS OF THIS GREAT WOMEN
THANK YOU.
THESE PLATE PLEASE BRING THE
NAME. TO THE DEATH SO THAT WE
CAN MEMORIALIZE HER.
YOU HAVE ANOTHER MAJOR IN IN
MEMORY YES SENATOR BATES THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I ALSO RISE
TO A JOURNEY THE MEMORY OF
WALLACE EUGENE DO SLAYER.
WHO PASSED AWAY MARCH TENTH AT
THE AGE OF NINETY NINE
ORIGINALLY FROM SOUTH DAKOTA
WALLACE SPENT MOST OF HIS LIFE
IN SOUTHERN ORANGE COUNTY?
HE WAS PROUD OF BECOMING AN
EAGLE SCOUT AS A YOUNG BOY AND
LATER IN LIFE SERVED OUR COUNTRY.
DURING WRLD WAR TWO AS A MEMBER
OF THE COAST GUARD BECOMING THE
YOUNGEST CHIEF PETTY OFFICER ON
THE WEST COAST DURING HIS
SERVICE.
FOLLOWING IN HIS FAMILY
FOOTSTEPS HE SPENT HIS CAREER AS
A CUSTOM HOME BUILDER IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
TRAINING HIS SON TO BECOME A
HOME BUILDER AS WELL HE WAS AN
AVID SURFER IN BEACH VOLLEYBALL
BEACH VOLLEY VOLLEYBALL PLAYER.
SPENDING MUCH OF HIS FREE TIME
PLAYING IN BEACH VOLLEYBALL
TOURNAMENT IN SANTA NO FREE UP
TO THE AGE OF EIGHTY THIS EARNED
HIM THE NICKNAME THE SILVER FOX.
IN HIS LATER YEARS WALLACE WAS
AN ARTIST AND WOOD CARVER GIVING
HIS GIFTING HIS TALENTS TOO MANY
REVERED FRIENDS AND CHARITIES.
HE EXEMPLIFIED HONESTY HARD WORK
IN FRIENDSHIP.
SURVIVED BY HIS THREE CHILDREN
FOUR GRANDCHILDREN AND NINE NINE
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN I ASKED THAT
WE ADJOURN IAN WALLACE DISORDERS
MEMORY.
AND HOUSE OUR CONDOLENCES TO HIS
FAMILY ON THIS GREAT LOSS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES PLEASE
EXTEND THIS SENATE'S CONDOLENCES
TO THE FAMILY AS WE MEMORIALIZE.
MR DO SIR SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- ON
MONDAY WE LOST A TROLL BLAZING
FILMMAKER.
AND A MASS FULL TO STORE TAYLOR
ANDERSON PERSON OF JOHN
SINGLETON ONTO YOUNG AGE OF
FIFTY ONE HE SUCCUMBED TO A
STROKE.
JOHN WAS A FILM DIRECTOR
SCREENWRITER PRODUCER FATHER
FRIEND AND MENTOR TO MANY HE WAS
BORN AND RAISED IN LOS ANGELES.
AND STUDIED AT U. S. C..
AS A U. S. SEES OUR STUDENTS
JOHN BEGAN WRITING A SCREENPLAY.
WHICH LED TO HIM SECURING A
MOVIE DEAL WITH COLUMBIA
PICTURES AT THE AGE OF TWENTY
TWO IT WASN'T LONG.
BEFORE JOHN BEGAN HIS WORK ON
HIS BEST KNOWN FILM BOYZ IN THE
HOOD AGAIN AS SHE SCREEN PLAY
THAT HE WROTE AND JUST THREE AND
A HALF WEEKS.
WHICH WAS FILMED THROUGHOUT MY
DISTRICT IN THE CITIES OF
GUARDINO INGLEWOOD AND LOS
ANGELES. FOR HIS FIRST FILM JOB.
JOHN DID NOT SHY AWAY FROM
EXPLORING THE CONTROVERSIAL
ISSUES PERTAININGTO RACE
VIOLENCE AND POVERTY.
WITH BOYS IN THE HOOD HE BECAME
THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
THE YOUNGEST PERSON EVER TO BE
NOMINATED. FOR AN OSCAR AS BEST
DIRECTOR AND BEST SCREAM.
SCREAM PLAY AT THE AGE OF TWENTY
FOUR THE ONE ON THE DIRECT
SEVENTEEN VAM'S IN VARIOUS TV
SHOWS THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER
BECOMING A CLOSE FRIEND.
AND MENTOR TO MANY OF THE
ARTISTS AND ACTORS THAT WE KNOW
AND LOVE TODAY.
WHAT MADE JOHN A GREAT
STORYTELLER WAS HIS ABILITY TO
SHARE THE UNFILTERED AN OFTEN
GRIPPING EXPERIENCES OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS FACE BETRAYED THROUGH
THE LANDS OF SOFT LOS ANGELES?
HE HAD AN UNCANNY ABILITY TO
ALLOW HIS MESSAGE AND THE FULL
N. LAYER OF THE EXPERIENCES HE
SOUGHT THROUGHOUT THE BLACK LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY TO RESONATE.
WITH THE REST OF THE WORLD.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY HE MADE
SURE THE FILM SHE PRODUCED AND
THE WORK HE I HE HE WAS INVOLVED
IN WAS AUTHENTIC.
MISTER SINGLETON ONE STATED.
IT IS MY STORY.
I LIVED IT WHAT SENSE WOULD IT
HAVE MADE TO HAVE SOME WHITE GUY
POLLS HIS INTERPRETATIONS ON MY
EXPERIENCE.
AND MUCH OF THE CRITICISM WE
HEARD THIS YEAR TO CATCH ME
AWARDS WAS ABOUT.
GREEN BOOK BECAUSE IT WAS FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE NOT OF THE
ARTIST HIMSELF SO.
IT WAS FROM THE LANDS OF SOMEONE
ELSE AND JOHN FELT BEST.
MESSAGE MESSENGER WHICH HE
HIMSELF.
WITHOUT LOOKING APPROACH TO HIS
WORK BROUGHT ABOUT A RENEWED
SENSE OF TRUTH AND GRIT AND
FILMMAKING WHICH OFFERED VIEWERS
FROM ALL COMMUNITIES TO
UNDERSTAND NOT ONLY THE HARSH
REALITIES.
OF THAT BLACK PEOPLE IN AMERICA
EXPERIENCE BUT ALSO TAUGHT US
ABOUT FAMILY FATHERHOOD
MASCULINITY.
CULTURE AND ECONOMICS.
HIS WORK WAS NOT PURELY ABOUT
ENTERTAINMENT.
AND PERSONAL ENJOYMENT OR A CAR
COMMERCIAL SUCCESS.
HE ALSO A CHALLENGE HIMSELF
CHALLENGED US I SHOULD SAY TO
CONFRONT OUR OWN BIASES AND SEE
PEOPLE BEYOND THEIR EVERYDAY
STORY STEREO TYPES.
IT'S SOMEWHAT IRONIC IS -- LEASE
SUCCESSFUL FILM.
WAS A BIOPIC ABOUT ROSEWOOD
FLORIDA.
AND I CHALLENGE ALL OF YOU.
TO BE ROSE WHAT IT WAS ABOUT THE
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE THE
DESTROYING OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
CITY.
AND OUR TOWN AND FLORIDA ROLES
WORK -- BY THE CLAN.
WERE.
MANY PEOPLE LOST THEIR LIVES AND
TOTALLY DESTROYED.
THAT TOWN AND AND THAT COMMUNITY
IN ONLY SEVENTY YEARS LATER
THOSE -- VICTIMS WERE RECOGNIZED
BY THE UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT
SO MEMBERS JOIN MANAGER I
JOURNEYED IN MEMORY OF A JOHN
SINGLETON -- GONE MUCH TOO SOON
BUT THERE WAS WORK YOU'LL NEVER
BE FORGOTTEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
SENATOR PORTANTINO.
S. MATTER YES MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TO ADD MY APPRECIATION
INVOICE TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES -- MISTER SINGLETON --
GRADUATED FROM BLAIR HIGH SCHOOL
IN PASADENA I HAD MANY FAMIL
MEMBERS WHO LIVE IN MY DISTRICT
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT MADE
HIM A SPECIAL PERSON IS
SOMETIMES FOLKS GO OFF TO
HOLLYWOOD AND YOU KNOW THEY MAKE
THEIR SPLASH AND THEY DON'T COME
BACK.
CAN HE HE CAME BACK OFTEN TO
MEET WITH YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
DISTRICT AND GAVE BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY AND FOLLOW THROUGH AND
NOT JUST BEING AN INSPIRATION.
BUT ALSO HELPING OTHERS --
FOLLOWING HIS PATH AND SO I RISE
THAT MY VOICE OF THE SAD TRAGIC.
FAR TOO EARLY LOSS OF JOHN
SINGLETON AND COMPLIMENT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM A LOS ANGELES FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE EXTEND THE SENATE'S
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY AS WE
MEMORIALIZE -- JOHN SINGLETON.
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR WILK THE DESK IS CLEAR
ACTUALLY THERE IS ONE MAN
PRESENT IF WE COULD UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
I'D LIKE TO REQUEST TO MOVE FILE
ITEM EIGHTY TWO S. R. TWENTY
EIGHT FROM THE INACTIVE FILE.
IT SHOULD BE DONE GREAT.
WITHOUT THE DESK IS CLEAR SO THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME
pMADE.
AND WE WILL RECONVENE BACK HERE
MONDAY AT TWO PM THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE DONE
TODAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THE STORM TROOPERS RIGHT OUT THE
DOOR AND AND THERE'S THE
REFRESHMENTS VERY GOOD THANK
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ANNOUNCEMENT.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL
BE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO
PM.
THANK YOU MEMBERS